[Musique]
bonsoir à tous nous sommes en direct il
est 22h sur l'antenne de Public Sénat
pour suivre le 3è jour de l'examen du
projet de loi immigration au moment où
l'on se parle le Sénat débat sur la
partie la plus importante de ce projet
de loi celle sur l'article 3 avant de
retourner écouter le direct jusqu'au
bout de la soirée quelques explications
initialement le gouvernement voulait un
volet intégration par le travail avec
des titres de séjour pour les
travailleurs dans les métiers en tension
sauf que les LR n'en voulit pas ils
l'ont répété depuis plusieurs mois cela
a créé de la tension même avec leurs
alliés les sénateurs centristes
finalement ce que nous allons voir ce
soir c'est qu'il y a un accord qui a été
trouvé entre LR et centriste pour
supprimer l'article 3 et créer un nouvel
article cela a été et bien évoqué juste
avant la suspension pour le dîner et
pour en parler on va retrouver Mathias
araez en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle c'est vous Mathias qui allit
m'accompagneré toute la soirée
expliquez-nous Mathias il y a eu
quelques échanges à fleur et moucheté
juste avant la suspension oui bonsoir
Quentin absolument après avoir écouté la
gauche regrettter la suppression de cet
article 3 une gauche qui continue
d'ailleurs avec ses ses explication de
vote à regrettter cette suppression nous
avons assisté à une passe d'armes
gentille entre Bruno retaillot et Gérald
Darmanin le président des républicains
ici au Sénat a notamment reproché au
ministre de l'Intérieur de s'acaparer et
s'approprier le succès de l'accord entre
la droite et le centre on l'écoute euh
alors c'est extraordinaire monsieur le
ministre vous manquez pas d'air je sais
qu'en politique le culot c'est souvent
une qualité je le reconnais et vous
voulez faire croire que le dispositif
proposé par la majorité sénatoriale
c'est l'équivalent finalement de du
dispositif que vous proposiez mais
queeneni ou alors les groupes de gauche
se troupe pourquoi est-ce que tous les
groupes de gauche montent au créneau
parce que eux voient bien la comparaison
et et ils savent bien que la proposition
qu'on fait c'est pas du tout la
proposition initiale qui était le sommet
le paroxisme de la macronie en même
temps pourquoi on s'opposait et pourquoi
c'est beaucoup plus restrictif parce que
vous l'article 3 notamment c'est un
droit automatique vous fraudez et plus
longtemps vous fraudez plus la fraude
est dissimulée et plus ça vous génère et
plus la fraude est créatrice de droit
d'un droit opposable d'un droit
automatique que même l'administration ne
pourra pas stopper B nous on voulait pas
et c'est pour ça qu'on va le supprimer
voilà vous l'avez entendu Bruno
rotaillot qui tire un peu la couverture
vers lui une attaque que ne pouvait
laisser passer un Géral de Darmanin
rompu à l'exercice monsieur le Président
vous ne vouliez pas d'article
régularisation vous avez obtenu un
compromis politique et c'est normal
c'est comme ça qu'on fonctionne dans une
assemblée parlementaire la vérité
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé pour ceux qui
nous écoutent il s'est passé de la
politique parlementaire il y avait une
majorité pour ne pas supprimer l'article
3 et il n'y aurait une majorité pour
voter en revanche contre le texte
puisque l'lr naurait n'aurait pas été
majoritaire quand monsieur Marseille a
déposé son amendement pour pas supprimer
l'article 3 et évidemment mes amis de la
gauche auraient été très content de
faire tomber le ministre de l'Intérieur
en votant contre le texte final tout en
votant l'article 3 alors j'ai un
instinct de survie assez développé
depuis quelques années et donc je veux
vous dire ici que la politique la
politique c'est assez simple c'est se
battre pour des convictions essayer
d'avoir 100 % de ses convictions et
quand on peut en avoir 50 % et bien on
peut être plus heureux ça s'appelle un
parti de gouvernement ça s'appelle
prendre ses responsabilités le président
de la commission des lois et sénateur du
Rône François Noël buffet a sifflé la
fin de la récréation en expliquant qu'il
y avait bien une distinction
fondamentale entre la copie du
gouvernement et celle votée ici par le
Sénat la prise en compte du cas par cas
pour l'obtention d'un titre de séjour
dans les métiers en tension Quentin et
bien merci Mathias pour tout ces
explications et justement on va aller en
séance car c'est très important c'est en
train de se jouer en directant on se
parle et bien c'est le vote le scrutin
public qui est en cours sur les
amendements de suppression c'est que le
Sénat va s'exprimer sur la suppression
de l'article 3 on retourne dans
l'hémicycle pour écouter et bien ce
scrutin
demande à
voter c'est bon le scrutin est
clos donc après ça
tombe vous le vivez en direct sur
l'antenne de public n
345 mes chers collègues nombre de
votants 345 nombre de suffrage exprimés
329 pour
191 contre 138 le Sénat a adopté
l'amendement de suppression de l'article
3 l'article 3 est supprimé et les
amendements suivant
[Applaudissements]
tombe
bien nous en venons un article
additionnel après l'article 3 je propose
à Monsieur
Cabanel de
défendre vous venez de le vivre en
direct sur l'antenne de Public Sénat le
Sénat qui vient de supprimer l'article 3
qui visait à créer des titres de séjour
dans les métiers en tension car la
droite et le centre au Sénat se sont mis
d'accord pour une autre écriture du
projet de loi immigration avec un autre
article additionnel après l'article 4
c'est ce qu'on va suivre dans cette
soirée mais donc c'est l'information la
plus importante de la soirée pour l' le
Sénat qui vient de supprimer la majorité
de la droite du Centre l'article 3 avec
une nouvelle écriturearticle 4 bis c'est
ce qu'on va suivre dans les prochaines
minutes retour dans l'émicycle la
résidence habituelle et hors de
France donc en supprimant l'obligation
pour les employeurs de justifier que
leur offre d'emploi saisonnier ne trouve
pas de candidat en
France en effet aujourd'hui le marché de
l'emploi français ne permet plus de
répondre à l'offre d'emploi saisonnier
agricole ce décalage a été révélé de
façon criante pendant la crise
sanitaire les raisons si elles sont
multiples se concentrre autour des
problèmes d'attractivité de ces métiers
et d'évolution de la société et je
rassouterai également et de notre mode
de
consommation or malgré les
investissement permanents de la
profession malgré les investissements
également des pouvoirs publics pour
remédier à ce constat le résultat reste
20 cet amendement permettrait de régler
une des difficultés rencontrées pour ce
type d'embauche et c'est un département
dont l'activité économique et
principalement le monde agricole donc
qui sait ce qu' vous dit qui en
difficulté aujourd'hui merci
merci Monsieur Masset pour l'amendement
99 il est défendu merci Monsieur
KNE quel est l'avis de de la commission
madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
vous proposez chers collègues que la
situation de l'emploi ne soit pas
opposable pour le recrutement de
saisonné étrangers dans les entreprises
de production agricole je proposerais
surtout et bien que si véritablement il
il y a des difficultés je peux
parfaitement l'entendre les emplois
soient inclus dans la liste des métiers
en tension ce qui permettrait
effectivement que la situation de
l'emploi ne soit pas opposable et et
nous verrons sans doute tout à l'heure
un amendement qui va permettre
d'examiner plus souvent cette liste des
métiers en tension si tel est le cas et
bien effectivement il ne sera pas utile
de pouvoir justifier la situation de
l'emploi c'est un avis de retrait sinon
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre
même avis don je mets au
voix les amendements identiques avec un
avis
demande
alors avec une demande de retrait de la
part de la Commission sinon un avis
défavorable et même avis du
gouvernement l'amendement 34 est
maintenu il est maintenu très bien
l'amendement 99
retiré donc je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement
34 qui est avec avec les avis que j'ai
précisé qui est
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
article additionnel après l'article 3
deux amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le prier le
283 est défendu par Monsieur
Jade
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues droite
sénatoriale ça va vous
plaire le présent amendement a pour
objectif simple celui de permettre aux
personnes bénéficiant d'un premier titre
de séjour pour une activité salarié
d'entrepreneur ou de profession libérale
d'accéder à un titre plurriannuel de 3
ans le ministre l'a rappelé combien le
renouvellement des titres de séjour
pouvait s'avérer
difficile parfois cfcayen mettant les
salariés qui ont un premier titre de
séjour dans des dans d'immensees
difficultés donc nous proposons
effectivement
d'étendre le titre de séjour d'une durée
de 3 ans pour faire en sorte pour
alléger le travail dans les préfectures
rendre l'intégration plus facile et le
travail plus facile au service de toutes
et de tous et puis puisque j'ai encore
un peu de temps je voulais juste vous
dire quand dans l'article que vous allez
proposer qui intègre les modes de vie
notamment dans tous ces travailleurs
sans papier et ben il y a ceux qui
travaillent dans les cuisines des
restaurants et c'est ceux qui
aujourd'hui savent cuisiner toute la
cuisine française
merci merci la parole est à Madame carer
pour l'amendement 33 merci monsieur le
Président mes chers collègues monsieur
le ministre cet amendement av été
proposé bien sûr dans le prolongement de
l'article 3 du projet de loi qui
prévoyait donc la création d'un nouveau
titre de séjour MTI en tenstion hélas
notre Assemblée a fait le choix de le
supprimer je ne me fais donc pas grande
illusion sur ce sort de cette
proposition pourtant je crois que le
constat sur lequel elle s'appuie
pourrait nous inviter à décider
autrement vous le savez il existe de
nombreux cas où les étrangers sans titre
de séjour valable travaill depuis
plusieurs mois voire plusieurs années
malgré la la clandestinité quel que soit
les métiers exercés ces personnes sont
le plus souvent parfaitement intégrées
et participent par leurs activités à la
vie de notre pays hélas le plus souvent
les employeurs refuseent de prendre le
risque de déclarer ses travailleurs et
ainsi les laissent dans une situation de
précarité et de dépendance en leur
bloquant l'accès au titre de séjour
l'une des raisons de cette irrégularité
repose sur l'absence d'autorisation de
travail pour ses employés avec comme
conséquence l'impossibilité pour
l'employeur de les déclarer
régulièrement et par exemple de leur
produire des fiches de paye nous
proposons donc que la demande et
l'obtention d'un titre séjour mention
salarié puisse être réalisée sans cette
autorisation à condition que le
travailleur puisse justifier d'une
activité professionnelle suffisante je
vous remercie merci Madame carer quels
sont les avis de la commission madame le
rapporteur merci monsieur le Président
sur l'amendement 283 présenté par
Monsieur jade euh mon cher collègue vous
proposez en fait d'embler euh qu'un
étranger puisse bénéficier d'un d'un
titre de séjour euh en lien avec le
travail euh extrêmement long enfin de 3
ans le principe dans le droit des
étrangers qui souffre des exceptions
mais c'est tout de même le principe et
qu'on commence toujours par un titre
court un titre qui permet aussi
d'évaluer la capacité d'intégration donc
c'est un avis défavorable quant à
l'amendement 33 présenté par notre
collègue la présidente carer et bien il
vise ma chère collègue mais vous le
savez à réintroduire d'une façon quelque
peu différente le dispositif de
l'article 3 vous l'avez indiqué
vous-même donc vous imaginez bien que
venant d'être supprimé ça sera un avis
défavorable
quel est l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur
le ministre même
avis je mets au voix les l'amendement
283 avec avis défavorable de la
commission et du
gouvernement qui est
[Musique]
pour qui est contre il n'est pas adopté
je mets au voit l'amendement
33 qui est
pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas
adopté article additionnel après
l'article
3 un amendement présenté par Madame de
Monsieur Durin merci monsieur le
Président cet amendement vise à dénoncer
une une hypocrisie supprimer la
restriction selon laquelle une carte de
séjour métier en tension ne pourra être
délivrée qu'en raison d'une activité
professionnelle salariée et j'allais
dire cette hypocrisie au sens propre et
au sens figuré elle court les rues cette
mention exclut les travailleurs des
plateformes qui en droit français n'ont
pas le statut de salarié oui il faut
sortir de cette hypocrisie parce que la
relation de travail entre une entreprise
de plateforme et les travailleurs qui
lui sont liés a toutes les
caractéristiques d'une relation salariée
ces entreprises ne sont pas de simples
intermédiaires entre des prestataires et
des clients et les travailleurs de ces
plateformes loin d'être des indépendants
sont sous le contrôle de l' entreprise
ces entreprises fixent le prix des
courses déterminent des horaires
préférentiels organisent les condition
de travail au quotidien il y a donc très
souvent un lien de subordination comme
l'a arrêté à plusieurs occasions la Cour
de cassation et si on raisonnait par
l'absurde à contrario partons du
principe que ces étrangers qui
travaillent pour ces plateformes ne sont
pas des salariés en quoi cela
justifie-t-il qu'il ne puisse pas être
régularisé ces travailleurs contribuent
à des pan entier de l'économie et la
seule réponse du gouvernement est donc
de faire comme s'il n'existe pas ne pas
les prendre en compte ce n'est pas une
politique c'est juste mettre la tête
dans le sable merci monsur chers
collègues quel est l'avis de la
commission madame le rapporteur voilà on
interromp ce direct un instant pour tout
comprendre car on vient de le vivre sur
l'antenne de Public Sénat l'article 3
qui visait à créer des titres de séjour
dans les métiers en tenson a été
supprimé par la majorité de la droite et
du centre c'est bientôt le même sort qui
attend l'article 4 cet article 4 qui
vise à faciliter l'accès au travail de
façon immédiate pour certains demandeurs
d'asile à Fort tau de protection
international comme les Afghans et les
héritréens tout va se jouer après autour
d'un article additionnel après l'article
4 et d'un amendement en particulier pour
tout comprendre on va rejoindre Mathias
Arz en tribune de presse Mathias de quoi
s'agit-il cet amendement le 657 pourquoi
est-il aussi important oui c'est
l'amendement 657 déposé par la
commission des lois qui a permis
l'accord entre les centristes et les LR
c'est un peu le le pendant de l'article
3 censé permettre la
régularisation de travailleurs sans
papier à une distinction près Quentin et
bien c'est que ce n'est qu'un titre
exceptionnel et non plus de plein droit
comme le prévoyait le gouvernement qu'un
travailleur pourra prétendre à la
régularisation à condition d'avoir
exercé pendant au moins 12 mois sur les
deux dernières années dans des métiers
et zones géographiques caractérisé par
des difficulté de recrutement le
demandeur devra également justifier de 3
ans au moins de résidence ininterrompu
en France pour seevir délivrer une carte
de séjour travailleur temporaire ou
salarié pour une durée d'un an une
procédure strictement encadré qui
relèverait du seul pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet et ne créerait
donc pas un droit opposable à à la
régularisation pour les sans papierers
voilà cette nouvelle réécriture d'une
volonté du gouvernement d'intégrer par
le travail ça ne vous aura pas échappé
Quentin on peut forcément y voir la
patte des LR dans cet amendement des LR
refusant catégoriquement une
régularisation systématique qui pourrait
selon eux créer un appel d'air et bien
merci Mathias pour ces explications et
c'est ce qu'on va suivre en direct et
jusqu'au bout de la soirée sur l'antenne
de Public Sénat retour dans l'hémicycle
cette information faisait plutôt sens
dans les consulats c'est-à-dire avant de
venir qu'ailleurs et c'est donc un avis
défavorable puisque ou une demande de
retrait puisque c'est déjà le cas et du
gouvernement monsieur le
ministre je mets au voix l'amendement
405 avec avis défavorable de la
commission et du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté je
vous informe pour ceux qui l'ont dans
l'allas que l'amendement 264 a été
retiré ainsi que l'amendement
269 ainsi que le
265 nous en arrivons à l'amendement 515
pour un article additionnel après
l'article
3en vous avez la parole merci monsieur
le Président il s'agit d'un d'une
demande de rapport sur les conditions
d'accès à la fonction publique pour les
étrangers non européens et les
conséquences de leur statut d'agent
contractuel de droit public pour leur
intégration et en état des lieux des
difficultés de recrutement dans la
fonction publique monsieur le ministre
il s'agit en réalité d'un d'un
amendement d'appel puisque il ntait pas
possible de déposer sans que ce soit un
cavalier législatif des des amendements
au droit de la fonction publique mais
nous voulons ouvrir le débat sur le fait
que dans la fonction publique aussi il y
a des métiers en tension il y a euh six
s emplois qui ne sont pas qui n'ont pas
été pourvu l'an dernier dans la fonction
publique détail la fonction publique
territoriale et il semble absurde de ne
pas modifier notre législation afin
d'ouvrir la possibilité de ces emplois à
des étrangers non européens il y a des
beaucoup d'emplois pour lesquels il n'a
pas de nécessité d'être français ou ou
européens et il y a aussi dans les
emplois pourvus beaucoup d'emplois non
peu qualifiés comme dans les
collectivités territoriales par par
exemple pour les la les emplois dans la
propreté mais aussi les emplois
qualifiés qui sont occupés aujourd'hui
de manière contractuelle par des
étrangers non communautaires dans des
situations de précarité très forte quant
à leur statut de de travail parfois ils
se retrouvent momentanément en situation
irrégulière parce qu'ils ont des
difficultés parce que c'est un un
parfois un millefeuille administrative
que de faire renouveler son titre de
séjour ou obtenir une carte pluyannuelle
et ce qui aussi complique la vie de nos
collectivités
territoriale et et donc il serait aussi
bon que des simplifications et soit mise
en œuvre pour aussi les sécuriser dans
leur statut merci merci chers collègu la
parole est à madame le rapporteur pour
l' viis de alors à propos de cette
suppression de l'article 3 sur les
titres de séjour dans les métiers en
tenstion je propose d'écouter l'analyse
de François patrial le chef de fil des
sénateurs de du groupe Renaissance quel
majorité que que pense la majorité
présidentielle de cette suppression et
que cette interview réalisé juste avant
le
vote bonsoir François patria merci de
nous rejoindre sur le plateau Public
Sénat le Sénat qui a entamé l'examen de
l'article 3 avec la probable suppression
de cette article et un nouvel article
avec un durcissement de la circulaire
Vals de 2012 qu'est-ce que vous pensez
vous de cet accord qui a été trouvé
entre les membres de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est-à-dire les centristes
et les LR d'abord ce qui me satisfait
c'est le fait que c accord survenu entre
les frères je dis pas ennemi mais qui
nétait pas d'accord sur ce texte dans la
majorité sénatoriale va permettre qu'au
bout du débat à la fin de la semaine je
l'espère il yit un texte sur
l'immigration voté par le Sénat c'est ça
la droite c'est mis d'accord sur
l'article l'article 3 avec les
centristes du coup il aurait pu y avoir
d'obstacle à ce qu'il vote l'ensemble du
projet de loi maintenant il y aura un
texte de loi qui sera voté il a parce
qu'il y a beaucoup d'articles il y a pas
que l'article 3 4 et donc sur ce plan
satisfait pour le reste je peux pas dire
à titre personnel que la rédaction de
l'article 4 bis qui remplace l'article 4
ME
satisfaittis dans sa formule elle ne me
satisfait pas mais elle me satisfait en
ce que elle permet contre ce que ne
voulaient pas faire les républicains
faire une accroche législative qui
autorisera demain le fait que sur des
métiers en tension les travailleurs
immigrés en situation irrégulère
puissent être embauchés dans des
conditions qui leur permettra d'avoir un
titre de séjour c'est compliqué c'est
faut être un peu clair pour le faire
donc le fait que ça permette l'accroche
législative c'estd que la loi permettra
ce phénomène là alors je vois bien c'est
la circulaire Val se renforcé l'accord
s'est trouvé entre les républicains et
les et les centristes sur le fait qu'il
réécrivait un article qui serait plus
dur que l'article initial mais il
n'empêche que sur sur l'esprit et sur la
réalité c'est un article 3 B en fin de
compte puisque il permettra la la donne
législative alors on voit votre collègue
Sacha aoulier président de la commission
des lois de l'Assemblée nationale qui
dit ce soir dans le Figaro à l'Assemblée
nous rétablirons le texte ambitieux de
l'exécutif sur l'immigration on comprend
rétablir l'article 3 dans sa version
d'origine et donc l'Assemblée nationale
qui dans un mois en décembre va
détricoter ce qui est en train de se
jouer ce soir qu'est-ce que ça dit ça de
la suite du parcours de ce texte non non
attends je je pense pas que ce sera
détricoté comme tel et je vais essayer
de vous dire comment je vois les choixes
personnels d'abord il y a dans des
choses qu'il faut remettre par exemple
l'ame qui a été supprimé hier au Sénat
et qui je pense est une aberération à la
fois économique sanitaire éthique sera
remis à l'Assemblée donc l'article 1 la
M sera remis sur ce qui est l'article 3
je ne pense pas qu'on aboutira un
article 3 réécrit tel qu'à l'origine et
tel qu'il était dans le projet qu'avait
déposé le gouvernement je pense qu'il
sera un compromis entre ce qui a été
fait au Sénat et ce que souhaitent les
députés don je comprends parfaitement
qu'il reviennent à une mouture qui
ressemble plus à celle qui était à
l'origine qu'à celle qui votera le Sénat
ce soir et bien merci François patri on
le comprend il y a encore du travail et
encore voilà on n pas le le dernier mot
sur ce qui va se j surle ça ve dire que
le texte qui sortira du Sénat fin
décembre n'aura rien à voir avec le
texte qui est au Sénat aujourd'hui de
l'Assemblée nationale fin décembre avec
le texte aujourd'hui et bien on suivra
ça de très près merci Françis merci à
vous merci voilà pour cette interview
réalisée juste avant le vote qui a donc
et bien supprimé l'article 3 du projet
de loi immigration retour dans
l'hémicycle on a entamé les discussions
autour de l'article 4 je vous rappelle
qu'il vise à faciliter l'accès au marché
du travail de façon immédiate pour
certains demandeurs d'asile à fort taux
de protection internationale en
l'occurrence les personnes venues
d'Afghanistan ou d'éritré retourn dans
l'hémicycle pour suivre ces
débats cet article il propose simplement
de dire pendant que cette personne n'a
pas encore eu la réponse à cause de nous
pas à cause d'elle alors qu'on sait très
bien que la réponse va être positive
puisqueon sait que c'est une personne
qui vient d'Afghanistan et qu'en gros on
donne l'asile en soin à toutes les
personnes qui viennent d'Afghanistan on
la laisse travailler travailler payer
des cotisations payer des impôts et
cetera c'est c'est ça le contenu de
l'article et vous êtes contre et je
comprends pas je ne je ne comprends pas
comment on peut être contre le fait
qu'une personne qui est là dont on sait
qu'on va lui donner le droit de rester
on en est sûr on le sait simplement on
est trop long à le faire comment on peut
être opposé au fait que cette personne
ait le droit de travailler donc de
servir la société de payer des impôts de
payer des cotisations sociales nos
cotisations sociales les cotisations
sociales pour tout le monde nos
retraites vos retraites comment on peut
s'opposer à ça je ne comprends pas nous
avons fait ça pour les Ukrainiennes et
les Ukrainiens qui sont arrivés en
France parce qu'ils avaient la
protection temporaire tout le monde on a
salué ce système qui a très bien marché
c'est simplement d'assurer qu'il puisse
être cohérent avec les personnes qui
n'ont pas la protection temporaire il
n'y a aucun sens à s'y opposer
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquiez
pourquoi merci mes chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur
B je voudrais répondre à notre collègue
madame Vogel pourquoi parce qu'il faut
s'assurer que c'est bien un
Afghan que il a réellement
de Bonn chances de pouvoir
bénéficier du droit d'asile on ne le
sait que quand on a examiner le dossier
interroger la personne vérifier que ce
n'est pas quelqu'un qui va être un
débouté du droit d'asile parce qu'il
aura abuser de la procédure en se
faisant passer justement pour quelqu'un
de persécutter alors qu'il ne l'était
pas la parole est à Monsieur
brossa merci mer merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre au fond
Mélanie Vogel a dit beaucoup de choses
avec lesquelles je suis d'accord mais au
fond la question est assez simple de
savoir si on préfère que les gens vivent
de leur travail ou si on préfère que les
gens vivent des revenus de l'assistance
et je suis quand même un peu étonné de
voir les sénateurs de la droite de cet
hémicycle nous expliquer qu'il préfèrent
que les gens vivent de l'assistance
plutôt que du travail je considère et
nous sommes nombreux je crois à
considérer
que ce qui permet à quelqu'un d'être
digne c'est de gagner sa vie par son
travail en l'occurrence on parle de gens
qui sont demandeurs d'asile et qui
aspire à travailler à vivre de leur
travail à être utile à la société par
leur travail et en l'occurrence vous les
renvoyez vers des revenus d'assistance
c'est-à-dire je crois pour un demandeur
d'asile 6,80 € par jour que des gens
préfèrent de préfèrent travailler et et
la possibilité d'accéder au travail me
paraître une bonne chose et l'un des
meilleurs moyens d'intégration dans
notre pays
merci la parole est à Madame de La
Gonterie merci monsieur le Président
beaucoup d'arguments ont été énoncés
mais je pense qu'il faut quand même bien
fixer les choses pour ne pas développer
de de fantasme
irraisonné moi j'ai bien écouté les
arguments de de nos collègues sur
l'article 3 et le refus
de d'un titre de plein
droit privilégiant la possibilité
et donc la possibilité de l'autorité
administrative de délivrer ou non c'est
exactement ce que prévoit l'article 4
l'article 4 ne prévoit pas une
autorisation de plein droit il est dit
peu peu en en droit c'est ce n'est pas
doit bien donc l'article 4 devrait vous
satisfaire dans sa rédaction alors
ensuite il s'agit de savoir quels sont
les les les pays d'origine qui pourrai
être concerné l'étude d'impact parle
alors c'est un taux de protection qui
serait défini année après année très
bien l'étude d'impact 10 50 % regardons
de quoi nous parlons il y a aujourd'hui
9 pays dont essentiellement Afghanistan
héritrée et Syrie qui bénéficient dont
les ressortissants bénéficient d'un taux
de de plus de 50 % enfin la formule
n'est pas très orthodoxe en français
mais je crois que vous m'avez compris
entre septembre 2021 et septembre 2022
il y a eu savez-vous combien de de
personnes concerné et qui ont eu une
autorisation de travail
354 donc on est en train de
supprimer vous voulez supprimer un
article qui donc laisse la main
totalement à l'autorité administrative
et ne donne pas un titre de droit
confirm votre souhait et qui par
ailleurs viserait quelques centaines de
personnes qui en revanche n'auraiit pas
attendre plusieurs mois car le délai
c'est 6 mois puis ensuite enfin en gros
c'est au moins 9 mois qui pendant ce
temps bah soit travaille au noir soit
vivent effectivement euh de combien
d'euros par jour 6 € voilà donc euh je
pense qu'il faut que vous revisitiez un
petit peu votre appréciation sur cet
article 4 qui est beaucoup plus conforme
à ce que vous souhaitez euh que ce que
vous disiez ou ce que vous penseiez
dire merci la parole est à Madame
Brossel merci monsieur le Président on a
beaucoup parlé d'hypocrisie euh dans le
débat sur la suppression de l'article 3
euh on pourrait tout autant parler de
d'hypocrisie sur cette amendement qui va
nous être proposé de suppression le
problème c'est que c'est de l'hypocrisie
doublée d'un dénis de réalité alors
pardon je vais permettre à la réalité de
reprendre pied quelques instants dans ce
débat à Paris entre le 18e et le 19e
arrondissement de l'été 2022 à octobre
2023 il y a eu 12 mises à l'abri de
campement de de personnes 5000 personnes
mises à l'abri au cours de 12 mises à
l'abri je répète les chiffres parce que
ça a du sens quand même sur lesquels sur
ces campements il y avait et des
demandeurs d'asile en cours de demande
et des demandeurs d'asile statutaire des
personnes à qui la France a accordé sa
protection statutaire et qui en étit
réduite à avoir comme lieu de vie les
trottoirs de Paris c'est de l'indignité
absolue et vous proposez aujourd'hui y
compris au regard des chiffres que
rappelait Marie-Pierre de la Gonterie de
revenir sur cet article 4 c'est écoutez
au-delà de l'hypocrisie je le répète
c'est un déni absolu de réalité et nous
ne pouvons pas faire la loi sans prendre
en compre la
réalité merci la parole est à Madame
Rossignol c'est bon merci monsieur le
Président en fait j'ai bien écouté notre
collègue Philippe B je l'écoute avec
attention toujours et je pense qu' y a
un malentendu sur cet article 4 le
malentendu d'abord c'est que cet article
4 que vous soupçonnez en
fait d'ouvrir des droits à des futurs
déboutés du droit
d'asile vous êtes méfiant vous êtes même
précautionneux mais cet article 4 il n'a
pas été rédigé ni par Madame Vogel ni
par Madame de La Gonterie ni par
Monsieur brossa il a été rédigé par le
ministre de érieur monsieur Darman qui à
ma connaissance n'est pas le militant le
plus nobordeur que j'ai rencontré dans
ma vie on peut au MO voilà et vous
pourriez au moins faire le crédit à
Monsieur Darmanin qu'il n'est pas là
pour accroître le nombre de déboutés du
droit d'asile bénéficiant d'une
autorisation de travailler qui ferait
deux ensuite des clandestins qu'on ne
pourrait plus jamais renvoyer
adminima faites confiance à votre
ami Gérard Géral d'Anin faites confiance
à ses services et faites confiance à sa
volonté de
traquer les futures déboutil du droit
d'asile et croyez-moi d'un point de vue
économique vous faites une erreur parce
que ces demandeurs d'asile du moment où
il déposent une demande d'asile il
toucheent la D vous le savez et il vaut
bien mieux qu'il travaille puisque dans
l'article 4 tous les verrous ont été
de façon à ce que seul bénéficie de cet
article 4 ceux qui sont quasiment
certains d'obtenir le droit d'asile donc
je me retrouve dans la situation
étonnante baroque de plaider pour que la
droite du Sénat fasse confiance au
ministre de droite
Gérald
merci monsieur le
ministre je m'exprime en tant que
ministre de l'Intérieur et et pas en
tant que no bordeur
ne soyez pas ne soyez pas soyez pas déçu
non quelques mots peut-être sur
l'article 4 don j'imagine qu'il sera
supprimé dans dans quelques instants
malheureusement
malheureusement quelle est la
philosophie de cet article et je
voudrais dire à monsieur le Président B
qui qui si je peux me permettre il se
trompe il est évident que nous donnons
une autorisation de travail que dans les
cas où l'identification est évidente
c'est tellement vrai que comme l' très
bien fait remarqué je crois que c'était
madame de La Gonterie c'est peu c'est
pour le coup c'est pas doit donc là pour
le coup c'est pas de plein droit c'est
une
possibilité la question qui se pose
c'est les personnes qui demandent
l'asile dans notre pays est-ce qu'il
vaut mieux qu'ils vivent de l'aide
sociale comme l'a dit Monsieur brossa en
l'occurrence 360 €
Lada vont dans ce qu'on appelleadna
c'està-dire le logement
d'urgence plutôt que de pouvoir vivre du
fruit de leur travail légalement payant
des cotisations sans que cela n'ouvre en
aucun cas le droit en aucun cas le droit
à une régularisation quelconque en aucun
cas le droit c'est ce que nous faisons
déjà pour tous ceux qui ont passé au
moins 6 mois sur le territoire national
et c'est ce qui se passe en Allemagne
par exemple en Allemagne on a la
possibilité pendant qu'on est en demande
de d'asile et même l' pousse le bouchon
jusqu'à demande de titre de séjour
d'avoir ce qu'on appelle une tolérance
et de pouvoir travailler ce qui n'ouvre
pas le droit d'utiliser cet argument
pour être
régularisé alors il y a la question
évidemment de quelles personnes peuvent
bénéficier de ce dispositif en effet
nous avons considéré et c'est le cas
d'étude d'impact qu'au-dessus de 50 % de
protection mais on pourrait
imaginer modifier l'article 3 imaginer
70 % 80 % aujourd'hui les Afghans c'est
à peu près 80
% ce dispositif s'applique et puis a des
nationalités dont on sait qu'on va pas
leur donner en effet l'asile là on se
doute que c'est sans doute une manœuvre
un peu dilatoire et de ne pas
l'appliquer puisque ça va de pre avec la
réforme de l'asile qu'on va étudier pas
cette nuit monsieur le Président mais
dans quelques heures j'espère donc en
fait ce dispositif il n'est pas une
mesure d'attractivité ou pas une mesure
d'attractivité les pays autour de nous
le font il n'est pas en lien direct
évidemment avec le statut de l'asile ça
n'a rien à voir évidemment qu'on vérifie
l'identité la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que ces gens qui sont sur notre
sol puisque personne ici veut refuser le
droit d'asile est-ce que ils vivent de
laada 360 € par mois et donc le logement
payé par l'État à travers l'association
par exemple où est-ce qu'ils peuvent
travailler par exemple moi j'ai des des
cas très qu' je vois passer par l'OF pr
de personnes qui ont des métiers par
toutes ces personnes qu'on a sauvé
pendant la la mission harpagan
c'est-à-dire tous les les Afghans qui
ont aidé l'ambassade de France a été
plusieurs milliers qu'on a fait revenir
pendant la la chute de Kabou il y avait
les traducteurs moi j'en avais besoin
dans les services de police national il
y avait des médecins il y avait des
infirmières il y avait des il y avait
des gens qui avaient un métier des
diplômes et qui devaient évidemment
pouvoir travailler pourquoi le médecin
l'infirmière le le le le le traducteur
il a fallu qu'il attende 6 mois à 360 €
6 mois à 360 € alors qu'il a tout quitté
dans son pays pour commencer à à mettre
en place son métier en France alors
qu'il aura l'asile bon bon donc je
trouve que c'est une situation qui n'a
rien à voir avec l'attractivité ou avec
l'immigration c'est savoir est-ce qu'on
veut que les gens travaillent du fruit
de leur travail ou pas voilà bon donc
pour répondre tout à fait à Monsieur
benaroche pour terminer je voudrais
qu'on se fâche pas entre nous puisque il
m'a parlé 2024 la dernière fois mais
imaginons qu'il parle de 2023 je sais
pas si monsieur benaroche est pardon je
vous êtes voilà vous êtes caché au au
PLF 2023 monsieur bénaroche hors Ukraine
nous avons inscrit 320 millions d'euros
PLF sur laada et en exécution il reste
encore 2
mois nous allons exécuter grosso modo
275 millions d'euros hors Ukraine c'està
dire qu'on va sousexécuter c'està dire
qu'on a en fait inscrit beaucoup plus de
crédit pourquoi bah parce qu'on étudie
beaucoup plus vite les demandes d'asile
ça veut pas dire qu'il y a moins de
demandeurs d'asile ça veut dire qu'on
étudie beaucoup plus vite parce que
quand vous avez arrêté d'avoir demande
d'asile et qu'on vous dit OUI ou qu'on
vous dit non bah vous ne touchez plus
laada voilà donc c'est normal donc nos
chiffres sont sincères notre stratégie
fonctionne vous imaginez monsieuroch ça
a baissé alors même qu'on av pas encore
la loi immigration vous imaginez quand
cette loi efficace sera votée à quel
point on pour être encore plus efficace
sur laada donc voilà cet article 4 n'est
pas non plus une mesure d'attractivité
c'est une mesure où il faut savoir ce
qu'on ce qu'on veut est-ce que les gens
vivent de l'aide sociale est-ce que les
gens vivent du fruit de leur travail bon
voilà si l'article 4 est supprimé ben il
continueront à vivre de l'aide sociale
c'est un peu dommage parce que c'est
moins de isation c'est moins de
rémunération c'est moins de G logement
d'urgence et ça ne veut pas dire que
pour autant on les régularisera
voilà merci monsieur le ministre je suis
saisi de quatre amendements identiques
de suppression de l'article 4
le l'amendement 656 est présenté par
madame le rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président vous
l'avez tous compris l'amendement de
suppression que nous portons avec Madame
Jourda se situe dans le casadre de
l'accord qui est intervenu entre les
deux groupes de la majorité
sénatoriale et et
et le contenu de cet accord que nous
vous présenterons dans quelques
minutes explique cette demande de
retrait qui n'est une surprise pour
personne le groupe centriste n'était pas
opposé à la mesure proposée par le
gouvernement mais depuis le début dit
que elle doit être relativisée et je
voudrais simplement dire sur les
différents ban
que l'ampleur si je puis dire des
principes qui ont été mis en avant sur
ce sujet est inversement proportionnel à
l'importance du sujet qu'est-ce que je
veux dire par là premier élément de
réponse qui sera assez facile sous forme
de pirouette politique historiquement
les demandeurs d'asile pouvaient
travailler dans notre pays C possibilité
de travailler a été
supprimé par le gouvernement de Michel
Rocard à la suite d'un débat qui n
change pas beaucoup qui était celui de
l'appel d'air et c'est pour mettre fin à
ce risque d'appel d'air que le
gouvernement de l'époque a mis fin à
cette possibilité vous voyez qu'on est
dans un éternel recommencement je
pourrais également vous dire puisque
monsieur le ministre a cité l'exemple
allemand que nous avons pu voir dans la
presse ce matin que l'Allemagne était en
train de revoir sa position et de
retirer la possibilité professionnel
pour une autre modalité ils imaginent
d'un système qui est d'ailleurs pas
totalement saut de travail d'utilité
collective maintenant pour regarder le
fond de notre sujet est-ce qu'il y a un
dénis de réalité de notre part en vous
proposant cette suppression je ne crois
pas pour deux raisons la première c'est
que nous parlons d'un sujet qui est même
S sont des des personnes hein donc mais
qui est à la marge de la marge madame de
La Gonterie vous a dit quelques
centaines de personnes elle a
sous-estimé le sujet à notre
connaissance c'est en 2022 1150
demandeur d'asile qui à l'issue à
l'issue à à l'issue je vous prends je
prends des chiffres volontairement plus
favorable au soutien d're position 11
s attendez madame
1150 personnes qui ont bénéficié de la
possibilité de travailler au bout des 6
mois donc nous sommes vous me
l'accorderez sur un sujet qui est quand
même très très limité deuxièmement si on
était dans le cadre de la protection à
50 %
immédiatement ce nombre serait encore
plus limité pour une raison très simple
c'est que ce pourcentage de protection
que propose le le vernement pour des
raisons que l'on comprend bien permettre
à quelqu'un dont on est à priori sûr
parce qu'il y a plus de 50 % de
production ou du moins il y a une bonne
probabilité et qu'il soit fasse l'objet
d'une acceptation de cette demande
d'asile les pays à 50 % ça n'existe pas
50 % c'est une fiction arithmétique
c'est-à-dire que dans la réalité de la
demande d'asile vous avez des pays à
très fort niveau de protection type
Afghanistan éitré Soudan et vous avez
des pays à très faible niveau de
protection type Tunisie Sénégal Côte
d'Ivoire et cetera donc les 50 % faciaux
si je puis dire sont le résultat de deux
situations qui sont extrêmes ce qui veut
dire que bénéficierait de la suggestion
faite par le gouvernement en fait les
Afghans qui ne sont pas les Afghans
d'arpagan qui sont pas les Afghans
traducteurs et médecins mais les Afghans
qui sont actuellement en Irak ou ou au
Pakistan
les des Soudanais des éitrens
c'est-à-dire des personnes qui n'ont pas
de pratique de Français qui sont donc
très éloigné de conditions
d'employabilité et imaginez qu'il puisse
être
immédiatement qu'il puisse être parlant
du 19e 20e j'ai bien écouté ce que vous
avez dit vous avez fait référence à des
gens que l'on avait qui étatit qui ont
fait l'objet de mise à l'abri et qui est
déjà titulaire du droit d'asile donc
vous voyez bien qu'on est sur un are
sujet donc pour revenir à notre sujet la
réalité c'est que une infime partie de
personnes pourrait être concerné par une
telle disposition donc je n'ai pas le
sentiment je n'ai pas le sentiment que
l'on crée une révolution juridiqueou
politique en supprimant l'article 4 en
exécution d'un accord que nous vous
présenterons dans quelques
secondes merci monsieur le rapporteur la
parole est à Monsieur Zurek pour la
présentation de de l'amendement
127 merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues cet article 4 propose de
faciliter l'accès au marché du travail
au demandeurs d'asile originaire de pays
à haut tau de protection sans devoir
attendre la durée légale de 6 mois de
présence sur les territoires national
pour travailler ainsi une personne venue
d'Afghanistan ou de Syrie pourra
immédiatement travailler sur le
territoire national nous proposons
évidemment la suppression de cet article
en effet en laissant à l'autorité
administrative le soin de définir un
obscur taux de protection qui permettra
des milliers de migrants à la solution
légale instable de travailler sur notre
sol cet article constitue de facto un
appel d'air je sais que vous aimez ce
mot à l'immigration massive et
irrégulière en premier lieu cet article
vient pervertir le dispositif de demande
d'asile déjà saturé en effet alors que
la France accueille un demi million de
demandeurs d'asile sur son sol et que
130000 demandes ont été recensées en
2022 ce dispositif viendra accroître la
pression sur les administrations
chargées de l'asile et constitua un
signal désastreux auprès des migrants
cherchant à atteindre l'Europe ensuite
en permettant un demandeur d'asile dont
la situation légale n'est pas stabilisée
de travailler cet article va favoriser
l'implantation de migrants sur notre sol
avant même que la situation ne soit R ne
soit régularisée excusez-moi le
rassemblement national s'oppose donc à
une nouvelle facilité de l'accueil des
demandur d'asile qui renforcerait
l'attractivité de la France comme
destination privilégiée de la comme des
migrants alors que l'assimilation ne
fonctionne plus que les services
administratifs et sociaux en charge de
cet accueil sur nos territoire sont
saturés et que les Français sondage
après sondage demande un arrêt de
l'immigration légale comme illégale je
vous remercie la parole est à Monsieur
Dufour l'amendement 365 est défendu et
enfin à Monsieur ravier pour
l'amendement
[Musique]
531 calmez-vous monsieur le Président
mes chers collègues l'article 3 est
celui qui a fait couler le plus d'ancre
et de salive mais parlons de cet article
4 qui accélère l'entrée sur le marché
des demandeurs d'asile on ne parle même
pas des réfugiés quand vous savez que 60
% des demandeurs d'asile sont débouttés
c'est en être dégoûté automatique vous
arrivez en France vous déposez votre
demande d'asile quelques jours plus tard
vous voilà au travail ces agents
économiques étrangers sont une obè pour
ne surtout rien changer il faut cesser
avec l'argument utilitariste le droit
d'asile n'a rien à voir avec
l'immigration économique monsieur
Darmanin appelé à être gentil avec les
gentils et méchant avec les méchants
mais il faut sortir de cette vision
maniquenne en l'occurrence ici votre
texte considère que les gentils ce sont
ceux que vous pouvez payer pas cher
alors qu'ils sont probablement sur notre
sol dans une démarche de clandestinité
finalement vous tendez à supprimer les
frontières entre régularité et
irrégularité en ouvrant le marché du
travail à la terre entière vous répondez
ainsi Monsieur le Ministre à la demande
de l'extrême gauche qui en appel au
droit au travail inconditionnel vous
vous apprêtez à ouvrir une boîte de
Pandore d'immigration cascade ne venez
pas ensuite vous plaindre de la
prétendue fatalité de l'immigration
clandestine de l'embolie des tribunaux
administratifs de ne pas réussir à tenir
le rythme de des expulsions et nous nous
retrouverons ici dans 18 mois pour
étudier la 31e loi sur l'immigration si
vous espérez séduire quelques chefs
d'entreprise avec cette vision
courttermiste je rappelle que c'est leur
compétitivité qui finira par être
impacté par la charge sociale entraîné
par le chômage des Français
l'immigration clandestine régularisée et
et le regroupement familial qui vient
avec permettez-moi de citer l'actuel
patron du mdeef qui affirmé ce samedi 4
novembre qu'il y a beaucoup de chômeurs
dans toutes les régions de France et que
notre première responsabilité c'est de
les ramener vers l'emploi alors mes
chers collègues je vous invite à rejeter
sans hésitation cette mesure piège et
hors sujet en votant cet amendement 531
rectifié merci là Monsieur le Ministre
j'ai compris que votre avis était
défavorable il est la parole est à
Madame de La Gonterie pour explication
de vote merci monsieur le Président
notre vote sera également défavorable
mais si comme j'ai j'ai donné le point
de vue de mon groupe tout à l'heure je
ne veux pas prolonger les débats mais
j'aiécouté attentivement les les les les
explications du rapporteur de de
Philippe boncarer et j'ai senti comme
une soit une hésitation soit une
contradiction parce que de deux choses
l'une ou bien c'est trop c'est votre
position sur l'article 3 mais dire que
vous êtes opposé à l'article 4 parce que
c'est trop peu
euh je je je ne comprends plus quel est
le fondement même de votre position donc
ce n'est pas non mais ce n'est pas
ironique de ma part parce que vous savez
on on ne change pas j'espère toujours
convaincre je pense que étant donné
l'enjeu s'agissant de quelques centaines
de personnes vous pourriez réviser votre
point de vue il ne s'agit pas d'une
ouverture abrupte du marché du travail
comme je crois l'a dit un jour par
rapidité de formule Bruno reetaillot
donc voilà on parle de quelques
centaines de personnes et les chiffres
que j'ai donné Philippe boncarrer ce
sont les vôtres hein c'est dans l'exposé
des motifs donc ils sont forcément
justes donc voilà je je je vous je vous
conjure de
réfléchir vous ne pouvez pas à la fois
ne pas vouloir quand c'est selon vous
trop ne pas vouloir non plus quand c'est
trop peu donc il ne faut pas vous
supprimer cet article
4sieur monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
demandé la parole je vous en
prie alors à titre d'explication d' puce
que comme les comme les trois
amendements sont tend à la suppression
je comprends que vous nous ayez pas
demandé notre avis sur les amendements
présentés par Monsieur Zurek et Monsieur
ravier ce sont des amendements de
suppression donc par définition nous ne
pouvions pas exprimer de point de vue
mais je préfère par avance anticiper sur
les observations qui ne seront prob qui
ne manqu courend probablement pas en
disant voilà on va quitter un des deux
corapporteurs monsieur bon carer qui est
effectivement le rapporteur centriste
pour la rapporteur LR bonjour muriol
Jourda bonjour merci de nous avoir
rejoint en direct ici en salle des
conférences la salle qui justoue les
débats qui se tiant en ce moment sur ce
projetimmigration une réaction déjà sur
la suppression de l'article 3 on le
comprend ça fait partie de l'accord avec
vos alliés centriste aussi hein la
supression l'article 4 qui va intervenir
dans les prochaines minutes et ensuite
va y avoir un autre débat qui va
s'ouvrir sur une un autre article qui
est très important vous pouvez nous
expliquer oui effectivement la majorité
sénatoriale a d'un commun accord entre
le groupe LR et le groupe
UC supprimer l'article 3 je crois que
depuis le départ nous avons bien indiqué
que dans ce texte il y avait un article
qui n'était pas acceptable pour nous qui
introduisait une régularisation
automatique de droit des travailleurs
irréguliers comprend c'est que vous
voulez garder le cas par cas c'est ça en
fait la pierre angulaire de votre ce que
vous voulez ce que nous voulons garder
c'était effectivement le fait que ce
soit l'état qui décide de façon
casuistique de pouvoir ou pas
régulariser quelqu'un l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour existe déjà
elle est compréhensible d'à peu près
tous nos concitoyens on en voit
d'ailleurs des exemples assez souvent
dans les les reportages aux informations
de personnes qui sont en France qui
n'ont pas de papier qui sont
parfaitement intégrés et qui travaillent
et donc je crois à peu près tout le
monde comprend qu'il puisse rester sur
le territoire 7000 8000 personnes par an
voilà ça reste alors 7000 8000 c'est le
chiffre global il n'y a pas euh
effectivement que ce motif de
régularisation mais euh effectivement il
y a des gens qui peuvent mériter de
rester en France mais on ne peut pas euh
l'État ne peut pas se décharger de son
rôle régalien de maîtriser l'immigration
en introduisant euh une clause de
régularisation automatique qui en plus
est ce qu'on peut appeler une prime à la
fraude puisqu'il suffit de démontrer
qu'on a frudé suffisamment longtemps et
suffisamment habilement pour
automatiquement bénéficier d'un droit à
rester sur le territoire sans aucun
contrôle de l'État alors ce que vous
avez voté sur la suppression de
l'article 3 et l'article 4 dans les
prochaines minutes ça permet à la
majorité de la droite et du centre de
trouver un accord sur l'ensemble du
projet de loi il devrait plus y avoir
maintenant d'obstacle à ce que la
majorité du Sénat vote sur ce projet de
loi immigration en revanche lorsque le
texte va arriver à l'Assemblée nationale
on voit déjà l'aile gauche de la
macronie qui dit vouloir rétablir
l'article 3 dans sa version proche de
celle voulue par le gouvernement c'est
ce que dit notamment Sacha est le
président macroniste renaissance de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale qu'est-ce que vous lui
répondez il ne faut pas détricoter le
travail du Sénat écoutez chaque chambre
fait ce qu'elle a envie de faire ou ce
qu'elle peut faire car la volonté de
Monsieur Houlier est sa volonté vous
l'avez dit c'est l'aile gauche de la
majorité relative du président une
majorité relative qui est est clivée de
surcroix entre deux positionnements un
plus à droite et un plus à gauche nous
verrons ce que Monsieur Houlier est en
capacité de
faire moi moi je ne sais pas ça n'est
évidemment pas la fin du feuilleton mais
moi je je suis au Sénat je suis
rapporteur au Sénat nous allons sortir
un texte au Sénat l'Assemblée nationale
y travaillera il peut-être un peu
inélégant de ne même pas attendre la fin
du vote au Sénat pour déjà indiquer que
ce travail sera balayé et il rappelle
aussi que l'ASS nationale a le dernier
mot l'Assemblée nationale a le dernier
mot bien sûr que l'Assemblée nationale
le dernier mot pourouz perdre à la fin
ce projet de pourz pas avoir gain de
cause sur le texte écoutez moi je suis
assez lucide parce que c'est une
question extrêmement factuelle sur le
pouvoir que peut avoir le Sénat le Sénat
a le pouvoir en ayant une majorité
de mettre en œuvre un texte qui
convienne à la majorité sénatoriale oui
mais vous avez pas eu des garanties de
la part du ministre sur ce que vous
vouliz comme ligne rouge ce sera la fin
dans le texte y compris après l'examen
de l'Assemblée nationale alors vous
allez directement vous la commission
mixte paritaire nous n'avons non mais on
avait entendu effectivement l'exécutif
qui était voilà très amène avec vous qui
qui vous donnez des garanties sur ce que
vous vouliez dans le texte on a entendu
effectivement je l' entendu comme vous
mais je l'ai pas sollicité monsieur le
ministre de l'Intérieur qui
effectivement nous a dit qu'il suivait à
peu près tout ce que nous faisons et
tout ce que nous voulons faire ça n'est
pas tout à fait le cas comme on peut
s'en apercevoir aujourd'hui puisqu'on a
un certain nombre d'avis défavorables
mais nous n'avons pas discuté et
échanger quoi que ce soit avec le
ministre de l'Intérieur notre position a
toujours été claire nous ne faisons que
mettre en œuvre la position que nous
avions affirmé dès le début de la
discussion de ce texte et bien merci
merci Mirel J on le comprend ce n'est
pas la fin du feuilleton autour de
l'article 3 nous retourne dans
l'hémicycle puisque et bien il devrait y
avoir la suppression de l'article 4 dans
les toutes prochaines minutes merci à
vous madame Janda merci l'avis euh du
Gouvernement est
défavorable le scrutin est
ouvert
voilà vous assistez à ce vote en direct
sur l'antenne de Public Sénat 22h54
l'article 4 vise à faciliter l'accès au
marché du travail de façon quasi
immédiate pour certains demandeurs
d'asile à fort taux de protection
internationale ce sont et bien des
personnes venues des pays comme
l'Afghanistan et l'héritrée mais la
droite et le centre se sont mis d'accord
pour supprimer cet article et viendra
ensuite l'examen et bien de cette C
nouvel article additionnel après
l'article 4 et cet amendement 657 qui
est aussi la clé de voûe de l'accord
entre sénateur LR et centriste tel que
bien il a été scellé hier soir le
scrutin public est en cours cela
signifie qu'on va avoir la cartographie
de l'ensemble de l'hémicycle mais aucune
surprise à attendre puisqu'il y a cet
accord depuis hier sur la surpression de
cet article de la majorité sénatoriale
de la ré du centre on devrait avoir
logiquement une suppression dearticle 4
dans les toutes prochaines minutes mais
ça ne ferme pas le débat autour de cette
régularisation de travailleurs ou autour
de par exemple la circulaire valge
puisque ça va être au cœur de ce qui
suit cet article additionnel après
l'article 4 qui est un nouvel article et
surtout autour de cet amendement le 657
qui va donc être débattu sans doute
pendant de longues minutes dans les
prochains prochains moments on va suivre
tout cela sur Public Sénat le résultat
du scrutin qui est président de carè
est-ce que c'est bon voilà il reste plus
que le grouped à voter de ce qu'on
comprend est clos on va donc avoir
maintenant la machine qui va calculer de
façon numérique hein nombre de votant
345és suffrage exprimé 329 pour
191 contre 138 le Sénat a adopté ces
quatre amendements de suppression
l'article 4 est supprimé et les
amendements
tombent article additionnel après
l'article 4 je suis saisi d'un
amendement
de la commission numéro 657 qui est
présenté par monsieur le
rapporteur nous sommes là dans la
présentation qui vous a ailleurs déjà
été largement faite par le président
buffet des termes de l'accord au sein de
la majorité sénatoriale l'écriture que
nous vous proposons alors quelques
observations rapides premièrement nous
représentons nos concitoyens ils veulent
que nous prenions nos responsabilité ils
veulent un texte grâce à cet accord le
Sénat aura la
possibilité de voter un texte à l'issue
de ces débats deuxièmement nos
concitoyens nous demande de démontrer
que nous sommes capables de surmonter
nos
désaccords nous
aurons apporter la preuve que nous en
étions capables à travers l'accord qui
est présenté
troisièmement hier
soir vous avez nous avons pris
connaissance d'un communiqué de presse
du président du groupe les républicains
Monsieur Bruno rotillot se réjouissant
que son groupe aura la possibilité de
voter sur notre texte 1 heure après vous
avez eu un communiqué du président
Marseille du groupe Union cent triste se
réjouissant du fait que nous aurons la
possibilité de nous aurons la
possibilité de voter sur un texte qui
reprend les idées les souhaits les
désidératat du groupe centriste et tout
à l'heure vous avez entendu en début
d'après-midi le ministre
s'ofusquait rapidement en disant mais
mes chers amis vous me dites tous que
c'est votre texte c'est moi qui ai
travaillé ce sont mes idées c'est ma
c'est ma réflexion c'est le texte du
Gouvernement et c'est le texte que je
vous présente ce qui veut dire vous
voyez où je veux en venir que quand un
accord a trois paires que tous ces
paires sont satisfaits des termes de cet
accord c'est
que c'est que par définition l'accord
est solide quelques mots quant au
contenu de cet accord dont je maintiens
qu'il est solide au regard de nos regard
de nos concitoyens le euh groupe
centriste et le gouvernement souhaitaent
qu'il y ait une possibilité de
régularisation dans les métiers en
tension vous avez avec l'article 657
cette possibilité le groupe les
républicains ne voulait pas d'un titre
de plein droit opposable il n'y a pas de
titre de plein droit c'est au cas par
cas de manière discrétionnaire
le groupe centriste souhaitait régler de
manière solide la question de
l'autorisation préalable de l'employeur
avec ce que l'on a appelé l'accroche
législative vous avez cette accroche
législative et la dispense de
l'autorisation de l'employeur le groupe
des Républicains nous alertait sur le
fait qu'il y avait une attention
apportée à l'ordre public qu'il y avait
une attention apportée à la réalité de
l'activité professionnelle allégué tous
ces éléments figurent dans les critères
qui seront pris en compte
par les préfets vous avez donc une
solution qui répond bien aux
préoccupations monsieur le ministre a
regretté que le Parlement dans son
raisonnement qui est bien sûr fort
habile que le Parlement en transférant
la décision cas par cas au préfet se
dessaisisse de la possibilité de fixer
lui-même les critères mais à partir du
moment où nous voulons justement qu'il y
ait un examen spécifique et qu'on puisse
aller vérifier la réalité du travail
alléguer comprenez que ce ne peut pas
être les critères législatifs qui fixent
cela et qu'il fallait bien à cet égard
un titre qui soit étudieré dans le cadre
de ce pouvoir discrtionnaire et vous
nous avez donné j'en AAI quasiment
terminé monsieur le ministre dans votre
présentation lundi un argument
supplémentaire en j'avoue en ce qui me
concerne ouvrant des horizons je n'avais
pas en tête le chiffre que vous avez
donné c'est-à-dire que au moins la
moitié des salariés étrangers dans notre
pays avaient comme employeurs eux-mêmes
un étranger je n'avais pas en tête cette
répartition des choses et effectivement
dans ces conditions je comprends quand
même que nos collègues et souhaité
vérifier la réalité des éléments à
travers cela vous comprendrez chers
collègues si je puis me permettre un
mauvais jeun de mot à cette heure-ci que
le texte est migré de l'article 3 à
l'article 4 bis cela ne me paraît pas un
très grand voyage nous ne devrions
perdre personne dans ce voyage et c'est
une belle promesse pour la suite du
texte merci monsieur le
rapporteur sur cet amendement
657 je suis saisi de 19 sous-amendements
le premier d'entre eux le 658 est
présenté par Madame de La Gonterie
mais il faut présenter votre
sous-amendement ma cher collègue et les
explications de vote se feront tout à
l'heure dans quelques dizaines de
minutes je je j'entends monsieur le
Président mais si vous voulez comme on a
eu une communication de la droite à la
droite nous sommes en direct sur aninea
pour suivre ce 3è jour de l'examin du
projet de loi immigration pour tout
comprendre on va rejoindre notre
journaliste Mathias Arz en tribune de
presse Mathias expliquez-nous on vient
d'assister à deux moments importants
n'est-ce pas expliquez-nous tout et ben
écoutez Quentin après l'article 3 c'est
donc l'article 4 qui a été supprimé par
euh l'accord signé entre les LR et les
centristes alors rapidement pour vous
rappeler cet
cet article 4 il prévoyait de donner la
possibilité à certains demandeurs
d'asile à fort taux de protection
international par exemple les éitréens
les Syriens ou encore euh les Afghans la
possibilité de travailler immédi
imméiatement après avoir posé leur
demande d'asile contrairement à la
situation actuelle qui leur permet
seulement de travailler à partir de 6
mois suite à leur demande d'asile voilà
donc cet article 4 il est tombé puisque
vous le savez il est sous le coup de
l'accord signé entre les LR et les
centristes un accord qui a forcément un
pendant et le pendant de cet accord et
bien c'est ce fameux amendement 657 qui
est en train d'être discuté un
amendement qui doit venir contrebalancer
la suppression de l'article 3 qui comme
vous le savez Quentin prévoyait la
possibilité de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papier alors cette cet
amendement 657 il a il a une distinction
quand même avec cet article 3 et
laissez-moi vous l'expliquer c'est que
ce n'est qu'un titre exceptionnel et
seulement exceptionnel et non plus de
plein droit comme le prévoyait le
gouvernement qu'un travailleur pourra
prétendre à la régularisation à
condition d'avoir exercé pendant au
moins 12 mois sur les deux dernières
années dans les métiers et zonees
caractérisé par des difficultés de
recrutement le demandeur devra également
justifier de 3 ans au moins de résidence
ininterrompu en France pour se voir
délivrer une carte une carte de séjour
travailleur temporaire ou salarié d'un
an une procédure strictement encadré qui
relèverait du seul pouvoir
discrétionnaire des préfets et ne
créerait donc pas un droit opposable à
la régularisation pour les sans papier
voilà cette nouvelle réécriture qui est
donc en train d'être débatue il y a
également des des sous-amendements de la
gauche qui vont venir apporter des
compléments à cet amendement 657 c'est
un un amendement qui comme vous le voyez
quandtin à la patte DLR malgré un accord
avec les centristes et bien merci merci
Mathias on est donc vraiment en train
d'examiner le cœur du projet de
l'immigration notamment dans sa version
sénatoriale c'est maintenant et c'est en
direct jusque tard ce soir sur l'antenne
de publi Sénat l'accès au droit ne
devrait pas être exceptionnel il devrait
aller de soi dans dans la même lignée
monsieur le ministre vous aviez proposé
seulement une expérimentation de la
régularisation jusqu'en 2026 mais
pourquoi faudrait-il expérimenter une
procédure qui a déjà fait ses preuves en
France il existe déjà la circulaire Vals
et la régularisation existe déjà dans
d'autres pays comme en Espagne ou
plusieurs voies de régularisation
coexiste même il faut être très clair
sur ce point nous avons suffisamment
d'expérience à la matière nous savons
comment faire nous n'avons pas besoin
d'une procédure expérimentale ou
exceptionnelle nous avons besoin d'un
droit et d'un dispositif péren qui
travaille en France a le droit à un
titre de séjour c'est pourquoi notre
sous-amendement propose de supprimer le
caractère exceptionnel de la
procédure le 659 est présenté
par sous amendement monsieur
kerouche merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur juste une
remarque à à la façon dont vous avez
présenté cet accord politique à
l'allégresse et à l'euphorie qui était
la vôtre on sent bien que cet accord
politique a été une joie pour la plupart
d'entre vous notamment pour le groupe
centriste cette remarque est en faite
cette remarque est en faite ce
sous-amendement propose de supprimer les
restrictions selon lesquelles seuls les
étrangers qui exercent une activité
professionnelle salarié peuvent être
régularisé en effet cette mention exclu
les travailleurs des plateformes qui en
droit le Français n'ont pas le statut de
salarié la non prise en compte de ces
travailleurs est une hypocrisie nous
semble-t-il dans la mesure où la
relation de travail entre les
entreprises des plateformes et les
travailleurs qui lui sont liés à toutes
les caractéristiques et nous le savons
tous d'une relation salariale
contrairement à ce qu'affirment ces
entreprises de plateformes qui se
présentent comme des intermédiaires
entre des prestataires et des clients
les travailleurs de ces plateformes loin
d'être des indépendants sont sous le
contrôle de l'entreprise via des
algorithmes et ces algorithmes fixent le
pris des courses détermine les horaires
préférentiels organise les conditions de
travail au quotidien il y a donc très
souvent un lien de subordination comme
l'a rappelé d'ailleurs la Cour de
cassation enfin l'exclusion des
travailleurs des plateformes du
dispositif de régularisation ne peut
tenir lieu de politique publique le
gouvernement ne peut se contenter de
constater le caractère irrégulier du
séjour de ces travailleurs et ne pas y
apporter de
réponse merci le 670 sousamendement 670
est présenté
par Madame
oui le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire demande à ce qu'il y ait un
accès à la régularisation pour
l'ensemble des travailleurs et non pas
uniquement l'ensemble des travailleurs
salariés comprenez par là et ça rejoint
le débat que nous avons déjà eu les
auto-entrepreneurs et les entrepreneurs
qui travaillent notamment dans toutes
ces entreprises de plateformes et nous
savons qu'ils sont nombreux nous
demandons donc que l'accès à la la
régularisation soit fait pour tous les
travailleurs quelle que soit leur
situation salariés ou
entrepreneur merci le sous-amendement
660 est présenté par Madame Rossel merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président de
nouveau nouveau dénis de
réalité on vous propose parce qu'on
considère que c'est évidemment
totalement non pertinent d'adosser le
dispositif de régularisation des
travailleurs étrangers sans papier à une
liste de métiers en tension
par ailleurs critèr qui n'existe pas
dans l'actuelle circulaire Vals pourquoi
je parle de dénis de réalité bah
aujourd'hui par exemple le secteur
hôtellerie restauration n'est pas
considéré comme un métier en tension et
pourquoi il est pas considéré comme
comme un métier en tension parce que ce
sont déjà des travailleurs sans papier
qui occupent les emplois donc forcément
il y a pas de tension puisqueil y a déjà
des gens qui y travaillent c'est oui
c'est ça ça doit être être l'appel d'air
comme dit mon collègue remémy carnau
c'est surtout bienvenue en absurdi et je
le répète on peut pas faire la loi en
faisant bienvenue en absurdi par
ailleurs la liste des métiers en
tenstion est censée être actualisée
régulièrement elle l'a été en 2008 puis
en 2021 dites donc le monde du travail a
quand même un peu changé en 13 ans et
depuis avril 2021 rien alors Olivier
dusopt qui n'est pas là ce soir je crois
avait s'était engagé Olivier du sopt bah
non je crois pas ah oui non alors il
n'est pas là je crois il avait annoncé
lancé une concertation avec les
partenaires sociaux pour actualiser la
liste de ses métiers début
2023 je n'ai pas l'impression nous
n'avons pas trouvé l'information selon
laquelle cette liste de métiers aurait
été actualisée et les partenaires
sociaux que nous avons interrogé
eux-mêmes n'ont pas l'impression d'avoir
été concertés d'avoir vu sortir une
liste des métiers c'est pour ça
évidemment que nous vous proposons ce ce
sous-amendement parce que c'est tout à
fait inacceptable de faire reposer er la
régularisation d'étrangers de
travailleurs de personnes sans titre sur
un dispositif aussi
déficient merci le sous-amendement 672
est défendu par Monsieur présidentard
Merci monsieur le monsieur le Président
le gouvernement et la drénational veut
uniquement nous l'avons vu régulariser
des travailleuses et travailleurs qui
travaille dans certains métiers en
tension pourrait donc obtenir un titre
de séjour la personne qui travaille dans
un métier qui figure sur une liste mais
qui hélas souffre de nombreux défauts
tout d'abord forcez de constater que
cette liste est actualisée que très
sporadiquement la dernière actualisation
date de 2021 celle d'avant de de 2019
alors que la situation sur le marché du
travail on sait très bien évolue
beaucoup plus vite et si elle est
actualisé sa mise à jour se fait sans
réelle consultation des partenaires
sociaux de plus elle est incomplète sur
cette liste des métiers en tension de
nombreux métiers en tension manque ça a
été rappelé l'exemple le plus frappant
est notamment le le serveur de de café
et restaurant et on voit bien que ce
métier n ne fait ne figure pas dans
cette dans cette liste ce n'est donc pas
moi qui dit mais c'est d'après le
rapport qui a été fait sur ce texte et
ce rapport du ministère du Travail cette
liste n'apparaît pas totalement
représentative des tensions actuellement
constatées sur le marché du travail
pouvons donc prendre des décisions si
importantes si nous savons que l'outil
de décision est faussé
et donc c'est pourquoi nous demandons la
suppression de cette liste des métiers
en
tension merci amendement
ident sur lebien
661 sur le l'amendement
661 défendu par Madame Lubin je vous en
prie ma chère collègue merci monsieur le
Président nous nous contestons qu'au
détour de cet amendement les exigences
en matière d'activité professionnelle
dont l'étranger devra attester soit
rehaussé la circulaire Vals actuellement
impose à un étranger de justifier d'une
ancienneté de travail de 8 mois
consécutifs sur les 24 derniers mois et
franchement un étranger qui travaille
est un étranger qui s'intègre dans ces
cas-là pourquoi lui demander j'ai envie
de dire des preuves d'amour
supplémentaires donc nous nous demandons
de rester à 8
mois et l'amendement 675 qui est un
identique par Monsieur benaroche Merci
monsieur le Président je pense qu'il
faut commencer par appeler la réalité de
ce que vivent les personnes dont nous
parlons ce soir c'est-à-dire les
travailleurEs et travailleurs étrangers
sans ti de séjour les travailleurEs et
travailleurs étrangers sonti de séjour
sont privés de l'essentiel de leur
droits ça concerne bien évidemment leur
accès au droits par exemple en matière
d'assurance maladie mais cela concerne
également par exemple leur protection
par le Code du travail sans protection
ces travailleuses et travailleurs
doivent accepter plus ou moins toutes
les conditions de travail aussi mauvaise
soit-elles et sans protection elles ne
peuvent pas pas se plainre quand elles
deviennent victime de mauvais traitement
de la part de leur employeur or ces
traitements sont malheureusement
fréquents entre autres l'employeur peut
refuser refuse souvent de délivrer une
fiche de Pai cela peut être un moyen de
pression pour l'employeur qui promet de
la donnée par exemple si l'employé
accepte des heures supplémentaire ou
l'employeur qui veut sanctionner
l'employé décide de ne pas donner de
fiche de Pai tout est possible car
l'employé n'a pas de voie de recours
mais que se passe-t-il si la
travailleuse ou le travailleur n'a pas
de fiche de paix et bien il lui
extrêmement difficile de justifier qu'il
ou elle a réellement travaillé or c'est
bien ce qui est attendu de lui pour
prétendre à la régularisation qui n'est
possible qu'à l'issue d'une période d'un
certain nombre de mois travaillé au
départ ça devait être 9 actuellement
c'est 8 et maintenant on en arrive à 12
monsieur le rapporteur c'est là où j'en
viens à votre amendement vous demandez
des justificatifs pour toute une année
sur une période de 12 mois donc la
personne doit montrer des bulletins de
salaire cela pourrait paraître adapté
mais pour bien de travailleurs et des
travailleurs étrangers qui justement se
font exploiter par leur employeur parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de papier c'est
infaisable et c'est justement eux qu'il
faudrait d'ailleurs aider en priorité
c'est pourquoi nous demandons par le
biais du présent amendement d'abaisser
cette limite à 8
mois merci on en passe au sousamendement
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre par ce sous-amendement nous
contestons le fait que la régularisation
des travailleurs étrangers sans papier
demeure tributaire de l'arbitraire
administratif le cas par cas que
revendique les auteurs de cet amendement
pour refuser la délivrance de plein
droit c'est surtout et en pratique la
règle de l'arbitraire le plus total
entre deux étrangers dans une situation
similaire l'un sera régularisé l'autre
pas c'est le cas au sein d'une même
préfecture mais aussi d'une préfecture à
l'autre avec des inégalités
territoriales évidentes la délivrance de
plein droit n'empêche pas par ailleurs
l'autorité administrative compétente de
vérifier que les conditions fixées par
la loi sont bien remplies par l'étranger
il est donc faux de prétendre que la
délivrance de plein droit hate tout
pouvoir d'appréciation dans la
régularisation des travailleurs
étrangers sans
ditre sur l'amendement
671 la parole est à Madame
Olivier
659 nous avons eu l'occasion de le dire
représente un tour de vis un
durcissement du droit existant
c'est-à-dire la circulaire Vals hormis
les critères de métier et zone en
tension la réduction du dispositif au
seul salarié les mentions inacceptables
et flou relative au mode de vie et à la
société l'amendement insiste fortement
sur la non
automaticité le principe est clair ce
sont les préfets qui décideront des
régularisations formellement ce pouvoir
discr ire est mentionné à trois reprises
par son caractère exceptionnel son
caractère possible et son caractère non
opposable nous avons une opposition de
fond avec ce caractère discrétionnaire
pour ne pas dire arbitraire la loi c'est
la loi à partir du moment où un
travailleur étranger remplit ses
critères il devrait être doté d'un titre
de séjour et de travail tout simplement
mais au-delà même de cette opposition de
principe nous trouvons que la rédaction
actuelle avec ces répétitions rel
caractère discrétionnaire représente un
excès de Zè cet amendement de bon sens
propose simplement de mentionner le
caractère arbitraire de votre dispositif
deux fois au lieu de TR cela ne nous
paraît pas
déraisonnable merci le
673 monsieur fern vous avez la parole
chers
collèg monsieur le rapporteur vous avez
visiblement une mauvaise compréhension
de de qui mérite d'être régularisé vous
proposez de régulariser les
travailleuses et travailleurs je cite
temporaire cette proposition elle
témoigne d'une fausse interprétation de
la situation qui est très très loin de
la réalité pour vous apparemment les
personnes qui auraient besoin d'une
régularisation seraient uniquement en
France pendant quelques mois avant de
repartir c'est comme s'ils étaient d'une
certaine façon en vacances prolongées
mais mais la réalité est tout autre la
réalité c'est qu'une personne étrangère
peut se retrouver en France en situation
irrégulière parce que son titre de
séjour n'a pas été prolongé im imaginez
imaginez que vous êtes blessé lors d'une
guerre dans votre pays d'origine mais le
système de santé dans votre pays s'est
effondré heureusement vous obtenez un
titre de séjour pour raison médicales
qui vous permet de vous faire soigner en
France mais une fois soigné votre pays
est toujours en guerre impossible d'y
retourner or Votre titre de séjour n'est
pas renouvelé résultat vous êtes en
situation irrégulière en France mais
vous n'êtes nullement un travailleur
temporaire vous avez besoin d'un titre
de séjour protecteur qui vous accorde
des droits vous avez besoin de savoir
que vous pouvez rester en France c'est
ça a été soulevé à plusieurs reprises
une condition pour pour toute
intégration c'est pourquoi nous refusons
votre vision de travailleur temporaire à
la place nous souhaitons que toute
travailleuse et tout travailleur a accès
à ses droits pour cela il faut que la
régularisation ouvre le droit à un titre
de séjour plusriannuel et que ces
conditions d'obtention soient claires et
permettent la régularisation du
travail merci le
666 madame
SAÉ et donc notre groupe demande la
pluriannualité de de carartte de séjour
pourant la motion travailleur temporaire
alors nous rappelons ici l'objectif de
régularisation et chose peu commune nous
allons citer le gouvernement au travers
des déclarations du ministre de
l'Intérieur lors de la discussion
générale nous avons besoin d'une avancée
législative pour régulariser des
personnes qui mériteraient de l'être
quand l'employeur s'y refuse la
proposition des rapporteurs bien éloigné
de celle du gouvernement est tout aussi
éloignée de la réalité notre groupe nous
avons pu l'exprimer est loin de penser
théoriser ou accepter une immigration
utilitariste nous sommes fermement
opposés au dispositifs de correction
temporaire de la pénurie de main-
d'œuvre et bien au contraire nous
défendons le droit des travailleur à
vivre dans une plus grande sécurité
juridique et cette sécurité juridique
elle passe forcément par une visibilité
plus longue que une seule année notez
que cette pluriannualité limite les
sollicitations répétitives des services
préfectoraux déjà bien surchargés dans
la gestion des titres de séjour aussi
par cette par ce soutamendement nous
attendons renforcer les droits que les
odeurs de l'amendement souhaitent faire
bénéficier aux travailleurs étrangers
déjà sur notre
sol merci le 668 par Monsieur Dosu vous
avez la parole chers
collègu merci monsieur le Président non
mais je voulais quand même souligner le
caractère un peu lunaire de la situation
on a eu un un prés président l retaillot
qui nous a expliqué pendant des mois
puisque ce texte a été adopté en
commission il y a quelques mois
maintenant pendant des mois que tel
Atila l'article 3 disparaîtrait puis que
aucune trace de cet article 3 ne devait
repousser je cite même pas de nouvelle
rédaction sous un autre article c'était
une des conditions un fil rouge et puis
là nous sommes en train d'étudier donc
un article additionnel après l'article 4
qui est une réécriture de cette article
3 et puis
d'autres auteurs de cette proposition de
loi de ce projet de loi ont raconter
beaucoup de choses aussi pendant ces
derniers mois dans les journaux le
ministre de l'intérieur par exemple dans
le JDD nous a expliqué que le
gouvernement était attaché à des mesures
de justice envers ceux qui produisent
dans notre pays sans jamais poser de
problème d'ordre
public bon et ben notre groupe préfère
cette philosophie de justice nous
pensons que les conditions législatives
doivent se suffir à elle-même tout
l'équilibre du texte est de permettre
ses justicce envers les travailleurs ne
dépendant plus de l'application
discrétionnaire des préfets et donc de
l'arbitraire
administratif et donc nous proposons de
revenir à ces critères de justice
c'est-à-dire d'enlever la non
opposabilité de cet article je vous
remercie
676 676 c'est
ça monsieur monsieur le ministre est-ce
que vous voulez présenter s'il vous
plaît votre sous-amendement
676 merci monsieur le Président je
donnerai donc mon avis sur les
sous-amendements des autres j'imagine
après la Commission en ce qui concerne
le sous-amendement du gouvernement il
s'agit de de rétablir un manque d'après
nous même si l'amendement a été
distribué assez vite hier c'estàdire
d'exclure des période de possible
régularisation les moments de travail
étudiant ou de travailleurs saisonniers
ce qui avait été prévu dans l'article
initial du gouvernement si on met dans
le temps qui est possible pour la
régularisation par les préfets si on
regarde l'article 4 B il devait être
adopté tel quel sans les
sous-amendements notamment des des
groupe de gauche alors en fait vous
allez régulariser possiblement plus de
monde puisque des étudiants qui y
travaillent ou les travailleurs
saisonniers c'est des dizaines de
milliers de personnes supplémentaires
donc je pense que la volonté de ceux qui
ont écrit cet amendement n'était pas de
d'ouvrir davantage mais de de refermer
un peu donc je pense que c'est
nécessaire en tout cas c'est comme ça
queavait imaginé le gouvernement dans
son article 3 initial merci monsieur le
ministre le 662 est défendu l madame
linkel je vous en prie merci monsieur le
Président euh comme Monsieur le Ministre
finalement vient de le dire lui-même on
voit bien que dans cet exercice de
réécriture des articles 3 et 4
semble-t-il dans la précipitation même
si les tractations durent quand même
depuis un certain temps dans cette
réécriture probablement que les auteurs
sont parfois allés un peu vite en
besogne c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous demandons la suppression en
particulier de de l'alinéa 5 cet alinéa
fixe en fait un certain nombre de
critères que l'autorité administrative
devrait prendre en compte au moment de
l'examen donc de la demande de
régularisation pour motifs
professionnels euh or en fait ces
critères sont déjà aujourd'hui pris en
compte euh par exemple le critère de
d'ordre public qui est pris en compte
par l'article
l412-5 qui fixe une réserve générale
d'ordre public et qui interdit donc la
délivrance déjà aujourd'hui hein d'un
titre de séjour lorsque la présence d'un
étranger en France constitue une menace
pour l'ordre publique donc on pourrait
finalement se dire simplement que voà
une petite erreur que c'est pas très
grave de faire une répétition dans un
dans un article de loi mais plus
sérieusement le fait qu'on répète cet
argument là dans l' ligée 5 pourrait
nous conduire à à considérer que la
réserve d'ordre public finalement n'est
plus intégrée dans les autres examens de
titre de séjour et alors ce serait sans
doute considéré comme plus grave puisque
je crois que personne ici n'a
véritablement envie que soit délivrer
des titres de séjour à des personnes qui
en effet pourraient menacer l'ordre
public voilà donc il nous semble que cet
alinéa au-delà de sa redondance pose un
sérieux problème et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous proposons sa
suppression merci le sous-amendement
667 madame vengel je vous en prie pardon
excusez-moi euh merci monsieur le
Président alors vous avez ajouté dans
l'article dans l'amendement dont j'ai
oublié le numéro qui réécrit cette cet
article le fait que on devrait vérifier
pour pouvoir accorder l'autorisation de
travail le fait que
l'étranger l'intégration de l'étranger à
la société française et son adhésion au
mode de vie et aux valeurs de celle-ci
ainsi qu'au principe de la République
mentionné à l'article
l412-7 alors les les principes de la
République mentionnés à l'article l412-7
c'est facile il suffit d'aller lire
l'article
l412-7 mais alors les modes de vie et
les valeurs de la société française ça
c'est plus difficile et comme moi je
sais pas exactement ce que c'est je suis
allé j'ai fait une recherche je sais pas
exactement de quoi vous parlez si vous
savez de quoi vous parlez moi je suis
allé faire une recherche
sur google pour savoir ce que c'était
les valeurs et les modes de vie de la
société française al il y a beaucoup de
sources différent c'est au hasard fait
la même chose une enquête du CNRS de
2019 je vous en cite une parti les
Français veulent choisir leur manière de
vivre et cela se retrouve dans tous les
domaines de la vie acceptation du
divorce de l'avortement de
l'homosexualité du suicide de
l'euthanasie autonomisation refus des
contraintes épanouissement personnel
chacun veut avoir son mot à dire
l'indice de libéralisme des meurs a
beaucoup augmenté en 40 ans la moyenne
de Saint indice allant de 1 à 10 est
passée de 4,3 à
6,4 la progression du libéralisme des
meures est évidente alors moi je veux
bien mais je m'inquiète pour vous je
m'inquiète pour
vous
le sous-amendement 663 pour le groupe
madame lin Canel je vous en prie merci
monsieur le Président comme je
l'indiquais tout à l'heure encore une
fois sans doute la rédaction a été un
peu rapide alors tout à l'heure on avait
une répétition qui pouvait peut-être
plutôt faire sourire qu'inquiéter encore
que j'ai essayé de démontrer pourquoi on
pouvait également s'en inquiéter là nous
sommes sur une autre type de redondance
qui nous amène à vouloir supprimer les
alinéas 7 et 8 parce que que
figurez-vous que depuis le début nous
sommes en train de parler pour les
articles feu les articles 3 et 4 et
l'actuel articles 4AD bis nous sommes en
train de parler d'un titre de séjour
pour motif professionnel et que donc un
un titre de séjour temporaire
conviendrait délivrer donc à des
personnes qui travaillent depuis un
certain temps sur certains métiers ou
dans certaines zones donc on parle bien
d'une activité professionnelle or ces
articles ces alinéas que nous proposons
de supprimer demande de conditionner la
délivrance d'un titre de sé jours pour
activité professionnelle à la
vérification de l'activité
professionnelle auprès de l'employeur
alors de deux choses l'une ou bien en
faisant cela on considère que l'autorité
qui a délivré le titre a mal fait son
travail puisque précisément le titre est
délivré parce que la personne exerce une
activité professionnelle et je ne veux
pas croire que les rédacteurs de cette
amendement considère que l'autorité à
laquelle ils font plus confiance qu'à la
loi puisque je rappelle que nous sommes
dans le dans la situation d'un cas par
cas administratif et non plus d'un droit
opposable donc je ne veux pas croire que
les rédacteurs n'aient pas confiance
dans cette autorité administrative donc
si ça n'est pas ça c'est donc autre
chose ce qui veut dire que finalement on
se retrouverait dans une situation où
des personnes se verrait régulariser
pour des questions d'activité
professionnelle avec un donc un titre
professionnel mais ne pourrait pas
exercer d'activité professionnelle et ça
je ne crois pas que ce soit non plus
l'intention de ceux qu' ont déposé cet
amendement d'où notre amendement de
suppression des alinéas 7 et
8 merci le 669 madame mogel je vous en
prie merci monsieur le Président donc
dans la même ligne ce que vous proposez
avec ce nouvel article c'est que l'on
puisse donner des des titres de séjour
sans qu'il y ait forcément une
autorisation de travail qui qui aille
avec c'est retourné plus de 4 ans en
arrière quand on a justement créé
ensemble un titre de séjour qui donnait
aussi le droit à
travailler et le problème c'est que le
découplage du titre de séjour et de
l'autorisation de travail ça rend
complètement ineffectif le dispositif
voire complètement contreproductif déjà
ça amène à des délais et des procédures
en préfecture plus important alors que
on avait compris que le texte du
Gouvernement de la commission c'était
plutôt de chercher à simplifier à
accélérer les procédures liées au droits
des
étrangers et une mesure de
régularisation doit être vue comme une
sécurisation juridique du travailleur
déjà hors sol donc afin de s'assurer
l'effectivité du du dispositif et du
recours il faudrait que évidemment on
est au moins en une fois le titre de
séjour et l'autorisation de travail et
en réalité ce que ça veut dire c'est que
vous avez réintroduit parce que vous
nous dites depuis tout à l'heure bon
alors il y a un truc sur lequel on est
d'accord c'est que ce sera pas
l'employeur qui fera la demande ce sera
le salarié qui pourra la faire et on
aura pas le verrou de l'employeur en
réalité vous l'avez réintroduit après
donc c'est un verrou à postériori et
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire c'est qu'en
fait ce dispositif il va continuer à
concerner les travailleurs et les
travailleuses sans papier qui
travaillent globalement dans des
entreprises qui sont pas des entreprises
voyou ça c'est le résultat tous les
travailleurs sans papiers qui
travaillent dans des entreprises de
voyou qui ont comme business model
d'embaucher des sans papiers et de les
exploiter et de les laisser sans droit
sans cotisation sans salaire décent cela
ils vont pouvoir rester sans papier en
réalité c'est ça votre
modèle merci le 664 qui le défend
monsieur kirou je vous en prie merci
monsieur le Président en droit il y a
deux adages latins qui sont connus qui
s'opposent le premier vous le connaissez
tous c'est Duralex Slex la loi est dure
mais c'est la loi et c'est le parti prix
que vous avez pris avec ce texte du
moins la façon dont la majorité
sénatoriale l'a réécrit c'est le
principe de durcir au maximum les
conditions de la loi mais cet adage
s'oppose à un deuxème adage latin moins
connu
souj s injuria justice extrême extrême
injustice parce que à force de durcir
les critères du droit vous faites en
sorte en réécrivant ces articles 3 ces
articles 4 que la loi n'est plus
applicable parce qu'elle devient trop
dur et qu'elle contient en elle-même une
injustice et ce texte par votre volonté
par votre façon d'être inflexible vous
le rendez déjà inapplicable et c'est
exactement l'idée que nous défendons
aussi dans ce sous-amendement parce que
bien sûr on nous dit encore une demande
de rapport mais en fait vous dégradez
tellement les les conditions de ce qui
était la circulaire Vals qu'il nous
semble évident que le dispositif bricolé
que vous nous proposez doit être évalué
dans les délais les plus brefs et qu'il
ne doit être mis en place que pour une
délai expérimentale d'une
année merci nous en avons terminé avec
les 19 sous-amendements nous poursuivons
avec les amendements le
389 madame Vogel je vous en prie
merci monsieur le Président si ça vous
va je vais défendre tous les amendements
à la suite puisque les autres son merci
parce que vous inquiétez pas je veux pas
parler pendant 8 minutes
euh parce que non pas les 352 simplement
les quatre qui suivent euh puisque ce
sont des amendements replilis
l'amendement 389 il porte et je sais que
c'est difficile c'est difficile dans ce
débat là que nous avons depuis lundi et
ça devient aussi difficile dans le débat
public qui est le notre sur sur
l'immigration depuis des années cet
amendement il porte une chose très
simple c'est la régularisation de tous
les travailleurs sans papier
oui la régularisation de tous les
travailleurs sans papier et pas
seulement des travailleurs et des
travailleuses qui travaillent dans des
métiers en tenstion je va vous donner un
exemple et vous le connaissez parce que
je pense qu'il a été débattu de
nombreuses fois dans les débats publics
c'est l'exemple du groupe de la poste je
sais pas si c'est un métier intention
monsieur le ministre la poste le groupe
La Poste emploie par le biais d'un
système opaque de sous-traitant des
centaines de travailleuses et de
travailleurs étrangers sans titre de
séjour et comme tous les travailleurs et
toutes les travailleuses du groupe ils
travaillent tôt le matin tard le soir
pendant la nuit pour trier les courriers
et pour livrer les colis qui sont livrés
à la poste en bas que nous recevons tous
les jours mais contrairement aux autres
leurs heures supplémentaires demeurent
impayé ils ont reçu comme consigne de se
cacher dès que l'inspection du travail
arrive il travaill sans être déclaré il
bénéficie ni de la sécurité sociale ni
des protections prévues par le COD du de
travail par exemple en matière de
licenciement et généralement quand on
les vire c'est par SMS une telle
précarité la Poste La Poste le droit de
recevoir du courrier on reçoit des
courriers trop souvent on passe je sais
pas combien de courriers on reçoit tous
les jours on y est très attaché c'est
pas un métier en tension est-ce que vous
pouvez accepter que toutes ces
travailleuses et tous ces travailleurs
de demeure
précarisé sans
droit sans protection sociale qui n'est
pas droit à la santé qui n'est pas droit
à la retraite alors qu'il travaille
depuis parfois des années pour nous
livrer notre courrier et donc nous on a
une approche pragmatique par rapport à
cette question la liste des métiers en
tenstion c'est une usine à gaz par
décret par région par secteur je veux
dire c'est super compliqué alors qu'on
sait très bien que tous les travailleurs
et les travaill qui travaillent déjà ils
sont déjà là ils font un travail qui est
nécessaire sinon ils seraiit pas là et
le plus simple c'est pas de se prendre
la tête avec des décrets chaque année
très compliqué c'est simplement de tous
et toutes les régulariser et là on aura
les cotisations qu'il faut pour les
retraites on aura plus de dumping social
et tout ira beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
mieux merci Madame Vogel pour le 170 est
défendu madame de La Gonterie madame de
La Gonterie et et les collègues du
groupe socialiste le 170 là il est
défendu il est
défendu le 461 pour Monsieur
Brossard défendu merci Monsieur brossa
le
200 nous avons tro identiques le
239 madame de La
vous l'avez pas vous est dans l'adias
quand même dans il est
dans ah oui je je vois que le dérouleur
mouline mais nous en sommes au 260 au
239 rectifié qui est un identique avec
le 330 et 370 sont les tris derniers
amendements de la discussion ça ne vient
toujours pas
bon
bien le 239 est défendu le 330 monsieur
benaroche
oui monsieur le Président c'est un
amendement un peu de repli par rapport à
celui de de de ma camarade Mélan vauogel
parce qu'il se trouve que un certain
nombre de de parlementaires de
différents partis de l'Assemblée
nationale groupe de l'Assemblée national
et et du Sénat y compris d'ailleurs je
le signale le du groupe renaissance du
groupe moderme et du groupe l c'estàdire
des groupes centristes et et et et du
groupe majoritaire soutenant le
président de la République à l'Assemblée
nationale défendit des positions pour
essayer d'obtenir et de et d'avancer
dans un accord en faisant preuve
d'imagination celle dont le ministre a
m'a reproché de manquer pour notre
groupe pour trouver en fait des
alternatives et des solutions qui en
fait n'étaient pas des accords pour
essayer euh de rendre tout à fait de
vider de sans sens le projet de loi
initiale de du du gouvernement mais pour
essayer au contraire de trouver des
consensus pour le renforcer pour le
faire adopter bon la discussion monsieur
darmana vous dites souvent vous avez pas
vous avez pas discuté avec nous parce
que vous saviez qu'on refusait le texte
donc vous avez discuté avec la droite
bon qui de toute façon aurait refusé le
texte et qu'il refuserait d'ailleurs
toujours si c'était le même que celui
que vous aviez proposé mais vous avez
préféré ce type d'accord et de
discussion plutôt que de continuer dans
le sens euh d'un d'un d'un accueil des
migrants d'une d'une intégration par par
le travail euh et d'une
formation de ces personnes afin qu'ell
soit le mieux intégré dans notre pays
donc cet amendement est comme je le
disais un peu un amendement de repli
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait il propose des
conditions différentes euh qui supprime
bien entendu qui reviennent à ce que
vous souhaitiez au départ l'automaticité
euh le le non besoin de demander un
accord à l'employeur ni avant ni après
euh pour régulariser dans des métiers en
et dans des zones que nous aurions fixé
les travailleurs aujourd'hui sans papier
en France donc si vous êtes toujours à
temp monsieur d'armanet de donner un
avis favorable de cet amendement et vous
êtes toujours à temps chers amis
sédateurs de de suivre l'option qui a
été proposée par un certain nombre de
députés de
vos de vos groupes respectifs du centre
et du centre gauche merci Monsieur
benaroche dernier amendement 370
présenté par madame la Présidente carè
merci monsieur le Président sur les
marchés dans le bâtiment dans secteur
agricole pour les livraisons dans nos
restaurants la liste est encore longue
mais voilà voilà autant de secteurs qui
vivent en partie du travail clandestin
depuis des années cette clandestinité
est condamnée sans pour autant que nous
puissions offrir de solutions
alternatives constructives alors que
constatons-nous d'un côté de nombreux
emplois peine à être pourvu d'un autre
de nombreux étrangers en situation
irrégulière attendent de s'intégrer
pleinement dans notre société en pouvant
exercer c'est une activité
professionnelle en dehors de toute
clandestinité c'est une équation simple
à résoudre le gouvernement l'avait fait
en proposant un article 3 notre
législation est aujourd'hui dans une
forme de paradoxe le travail clandestin
est interdit et pourtant il existe en
dehors de tout contrôle les employés
comme des employés comme les employeurs
dans la sont placés dans la précarité
pardon en même temps les travailleurs
clandestins cherchent à pouvoir attester
de leur activité professionnelle pour
obtenir une régularisation même si nous
n'avons pas d'illusion sur le sort de
cette amendement nous proposons donc
d'aller plus loin en ne créant pas un
nouveau titre de séjour mais en
intégrant le nouveau mécanisme proche de
ce que souhaitait le gouvernement un
dispositif existant déjà celui du titre
de séjour salarié cela facilitera
efficacement la régularisation des
travailleurs sans papier ce mécanisme
nous paraît plus adapté parce qu'il
s'intègre au droits existant tout en
répondant parfaitement à un objectif que
nous souhaitons défendre l'intégration
par le travail merci madame la
Présidente avant de prendre les avis de
la commission et du gouvernement je vous
propose quelques minutes de suspension
physiologique et la séance sera reprise
à 23h45 dans 5
[Musique]
minutes voilà vous êtes toujours en
direct sur public sat
23h41 avant d'accueillir ici un invité
en salle des conférences on va aller
retrouver Mathias Arz qui se trouve
toujours en tribune de presse Mathias
expliquez-nous là où nous en sommes
exactement à l'heure où l'on se parle
s'il vous plaît et ben écoutez Quentin
on vient de suivre depuis la reprise à à
22h et bien la suppression de l'article
3 visant à régulariser les travailleurs
sans papier on a également suivi la
suppression de l'article 4 qui devait
permettre au demandeurs d'asile avec un
fort taux de protection internationale
leur donner la possibilité de travailler
on est donc maintenant à un article
additionnel après cet article 4 c'est
l'amendement 657 un amendement qui a été
déposé euh par la commission des lois et
qui vient donc un petit peu chapauter
cet accord entre les LR et les
centristes euh qui a donc qui a qui a
fait que les les les centristes ont
accepté la suppression des articles 3 et
4 c'est un amendement euh qui euh qui
vise euh notamment à régulariser des
travailleurs sans papier avec une
distinction toutefois avec cet article 3
et bien c'est que ce ne sera qu'à titre
exceptionnel et non plus de plein droit
comme le voyit le prévoyait le
gouvernement qu'un travailleur pourra
prendre euh la prétendre à la
régularisation à condition d'avoir
exercé pendant au moins 12 mois sur les
deux dernières années dans des métiers
et des zones géographique caractérisé
par des difficultés de recrutement voilà
le demandeur devra également justifier
de 3 ans au moins de résidence
ininterrompu en France pour seevoir
délivrer à une carte de séjour
travailleur temporaire d'un an une
procédure strictement encadrée et qui
relèverait du seul pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet et ne créerait
donc pas un droit opposable à la
régularisation pour pour les sans papier
voilà ça c'est le pendant qu'on réussi à
obtenir les centristes pour accepter que
leslr suppriment les articles 3 et 4
c'est une réécriture un peu à la SAU
deslr Quentin il faut bien il faut bien
l'admettre et donc depuis tout à l'heure
et bien on assiste donc à une série
d'amendements et de sous-amendement
déposés par la gauche qui était tombé
avec la suppression des articles 3 et 4
mais par courtoisie de la part du
président de la commission des lois
François Noël buffet et bien certains de
ces amendements ont pu être défendus à
présent et bien merci merci Mathias pour
toutes ces explications pour en parler
j'accueille ici Yann Chantrel bonsoir
Monsieur Chantrel vous êtes sénateur
socialiste vous représentez les Français
établis hors de France un mot sur ce que
vient de dire Mathias on le comprend il
y a le cas par cas c'était vraiment la
Pier angulaire de ce que veut la droite
dans ce texte qui fait qu'ils n'ont pas
voulu de l'article 3 et que en train on
est en train de débattre maintenant de
ce nouvel article après l'article 4 vous
vous dites qu'en fait ce cas par cas ça
crée de l'arbitraire c'est ce qui fait
que vous dénoncez cette nouvelle
écriture on a bien compris oui vous avez
très bien compris effectivement ça crée
c'est un pouvoir discrétionnaire auprès
des des préfets qui vont décider les
régularisations au comptegoutte donc ça
crée de l'arbitraire justement nous on
préfère que ça passe par la loi
justement pour qu'il puisse y avoir une
régularisation qui soit encadrée par les
législateurs B ce qu'on a assisté ce
soir c'est un peu à une tambouille au
sein de la majorité sénatoriale entre
les centristes et les les les alr et qui
est pas glorieux au ni au niveau de
notre institution hein même le
rapporteur s'en expliquaer en séance de
manière un peu contrrie c'est pas très
glorieux ces petites tamboules mais même
je veux dire même les LR à mon avis ils
sont pas complètement satisfaits parce
que eux ce qu'ils souhaitent c'est
aucune régularisation c'est pas ce qui
se passera avec ça mais ça n'est
clairement pas satisfaisant du tout
c'està-dire que nous sommes des
législateurs et là c'est les
législateurs qui disent on se remet au
pouvoir du gouvernement à faire une
circulaire pour que les
les préfectures les décident au cas par
cas ce qui n'est pas acceptable bien
évidemment le gouvernement lui il plaide
depuis un an pour dire que ce texte il
est équilibré entre monsieur du sopt et
Monsieur daranin sur l'intégration par
le travail la répression de
l'immigration illégale et et on voit
qu'en fait cet équilibre il plaît à
personne ni vous à gauche ni les LR et
les centristes c'est ça en fait le
problème de vouloir faire un texte
équilibré c'est que l'équilibre en fait
personne ne voit la même chose porte
surtout oui mais surtout on voit que
nous le texte n'est pas équilibré et
d'ailleurs monsieur duop vous le voyez
beaucoup au début là lors de la
présentation du texte on le voit plus du
tout hein il était même pas en séance
c'est ce que nous-même on a réclamé à
travers une suspension de séance pour
qu'il viennent euh dans l'hémicycle il
n'est même plus présent complètement ah
bah bien sûr c'est un symbole c'est une
reprise en main totale par la droite la
plus dure à travers Gérald armanin
d'ailleurs euh qui clairement euh est
euh la droite dure au sein du du
gouvernement qui a complètement repris
la main sur ce texte et ce qui est
particulièrement inquiétant en tout cas
et que nous combattons un dernier mot
avant d'aller sur une dernière question
mais un dernier mot sur cet article
qu'on est en train d'examiner là il y a
une suspension de séance mais cet
article qui remplace l'article 3 donc on
l'appelle article additionnel après
l'article 4 mais il y a aussi cette
question de l'adhésion au mode de vie
aux valeurs de la société française
c'est aussi quelque chose qui a été noté
comme le préfet devra vérifier cette
adhésion au moment de donner le titre de
séjour et on voit que ça aussi ça
provoque une levée de bouclier à gauche
pourquoiouié c'est difficile à
comprendre comme comme définition bah
c'est même pas c'est c'est quoi une
définition à mode de vie à la française
enfin qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
qu'est-ce que ça signifie qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire juridiquement derrière donc
ça a pas de sens enfin je veux dire
c'est c'est grotesque ça ça crée de de
l'arbitraire c'estàdire que même ça
l'interprétation de ce qu'est le mode de
vie ou français par les préfectures
qu'est-ce que ça va être c'est la
question qu'on est en temps droit de se
poser j'ai une dernière question même si
on entend que ça sonne ça signe le fait
qu'il va bientôt ça va bientôt reprendre
dans l'hémicycle mais on voit
sachaoulier qui est le président de la
commission des lois de l'Assemblée
nationale dire que dans un mois la
majorité Renaissance va réécrire le
texte et va reproposer et sans doute
revoter dit-il l'article 3 dans la
vision du gouvernement vous ça vous
soulage en un certain sens que l'aile
gauche de la macronie voilà puisse peser
aussi dans ce débat enfin je dirais pas
aile gauche mais on va voir déjà il se
revendique comme tel peut-être il se
revendique comme telle on verra si c'est
le cas si cette personne est isolée ou
s'ils sont plusieurs ou on sa pas trs
bienbi on sait pas vraiment combien ils
sont donc on va pouvoir assister
réellement ou est-ce qu'il va y avoir et
puis à la fin il faut qu'il y ait une
conclusion il faut que ce texte soit
voté donc il faut il faut qu'il y ait un
accord entre les deux assemblées on a
bien vu à quel point ce texte est très
déséquilibré au niveau de cette chambre
il sortira certainement très droitisé
dir extrême droitisé même et et donc
qu'est-ce qui se passera à l'Assemblée
nationale c'est toute la question
qu'onon qu'on est en droit de se poser
en tout cas nous même la gauche va se
battre également pour bien évidemment
qu'on réinstalle des articles 3 mais
nous on est pour la régularisation de
tous les travailleurs attention tous les
travailleurs sont papi pas uniquement
dans les métiers entention l'article 3
initial ne vous non il ne nous convient
pas on souhaite que ça soit tous les
travailleurs sans papier qui soi
régularisé et bien merci merci d'être
venu à ce micro pour une réaction et
pendant que on se parlait et bien la
séance a repris et c'est la rapporteur
LR Muriel joura qui a la parole en
l'écoute vous le voulez bien donner une
explication générale sur la position qui
est celle de la Commission et de vos
rapporteurs vous nous avez beaucoup
reprocher de manquer de pragmatisme sur
une situation de faite qui est celle de
la réalité de d'étranger en situation de
travail irrégulière en France c'est
exact cette situation existe mais je
crois que le pragmatisme n'est pas une
politique on ne peut aborder la réalité
qu'au vu des principes qu'on a posé
auparavant et vous avez compris que ces
principes ne sont pas tout à fait ceux
que vous avez pu défendre hier au cours
du débat qui était celui notamment du
droit au séjour nous ne reconnaissons
pas le droit au séjour des des étrangers
en France
nous souhaitons qu'il existe une
législation qui prévoit comment les
étrangers rentrre en France comment ils
y restent et quelle est
l'autorisation de travail qui peut leur
être donné dans la mesure où l'État
délivre et décide des conditions de
régularité des étrangers en France vous
comprenez bien que l'irrégularité de
leur présence ne peut pas créer un droit
à régularisation comme je l'ai entendu
aussi tout à l'heure lire irrégularité
ne peut pas être tolérée par principe
mais effectivement le pragmatisme que
dont vous revendiquez consiste à
reconnaître l'existence d'une situation
qui si elle ne peut être tolérée par
principe peut-être admise par exception
et c'est pourquoi l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour a fait l'objet
de notre choix comme façon de résoudre
parfois cette réalité qui effectivement
serait insoluble sans ce principe
pas de droit à régularisation c'est
pourquoi nous avons rejeté l'article 3
mais une admission exceptionnelle au
séjour qui est celle qui existe
aujourd'hui une fois que cette admission
exceptionnelle de séjour est reconnue
dans quelles conditions peut-ellere mise
en œuvre nous vous nous avez reproché
d'avoir encore durci les conditions de
la circuit d'arvals qui prévoyait
comment devait se décliner par les
préfets cette admission exceptionnelle
au séjour vous avez raison je ne peux
pas vous dire autre chose vous avez
raison nous avons durci les conditions
d'application de l'admission
exceptionnelle au séjour car tel est
aussi notre notre conception des choses
encore une fois ce qui est exceptionnel
ne doit pas être facilité et doit être
correctementcadré c'est le cas c'est le
cas de ce que nous avons fait dans les
conditions qui vous ont été énuméré tout
à l'heure alors oui une admission
exceptionnelle parce que l'irrégularité
ne peut pas être un principe et ne peut
pas être créatrice de droit oui une
admission plus dure parce
qu'effectivement nous ne souhaitons pas
que la régularisation soit simple et
effectivement c'est dans ces conditions
que cet article est présenté donc bien
évidemment l'ensemble des
sous-amendements qui ne souhait pas
abonder en ce sens qui n'adhère pas à
cette vision des choses nous avons émis
un admis défavorable c'est-à-dire la
quasi totalité des sous-amendements à
l'exception de l'amendement du
Gouvernement numéro 676 pourquoi parce
que même si monsieur le ministre n'est
pas venu avec le texte qui ressortira
d'ici il est entré je crois par ce
sous-amendement dans l'idée qui a été la
nôtre qui est de rendre plus
restrictives les conditions de
l'admission exceptionnel au séjour et il
a effectivement déposé un amendement qui
les rend plus restrictive donc c'est un
avis favorable sur l'amendement 676 et
défavorable sur l'ensemble des autres
sous-amendements monsieur le ministre
quels sont les avis du gouvernement sur
ces sous-amendements et et amendement et
l'amendement aussi évidemment le premier
d'entre eux 157 merci monsieur le
Président je je suis largement exprimé
sur le principe du 3 du 4 bis je vais
parevenenir en détail sur ce point c'est
un avis de de sagesse sur l'amendement
peut-être un point de de précision pour
Madame la rapporteur mais aussi pour
ceux qui sont intervenus dans le débat
et puis j'ai des positions favorables
sur un certain nombre de sousamendements
qui ont été déposés par notamment le le
groupe socialiste ou le groupe vert
voilà le le je voudrais ici dire Madame
la rapporteur mais aussi je dis aux
autres sénateurs on on ne durcit pas la
circulaire Val avec le C bis on va créer
une autre
circulaire c'est important de
comprendre pour répondre la question
madame la gonri Vals va rester Vals si
j'ose dire voilà vous vous le connaissez
bien mieux que moi
bon et c'est une circulaire qui n'est
pas Conseil d'État opposable voilà et
donc là nous allons créer avec le 4 bis
aujourd'hui et puis modifier j'imagine
laation puis modifier en CMP puis puis
puis puis si nous gardons le même
principe une circulaire nouvelle qu'on
appellera du soft on l'pp comme vous
voulez on
l'appellera je sens que ça vous je sens
que ça
[Musique]
vous euh je vais arrêter là mes
provocations sinon donc on une nouvelle
circulaire qui permettra la
régularisation de personnes qui sont
dans les métiers en attention c'est bien
ce qui est marqué dans dans ce texte et
alors là je suis d'accord avec a vous je
crois que il y a un mieux on supprime
l'employeur sur l'employé mais il y a
une réintroduction de vérification à
postériorie qui mériterait sans doute
d'être modifié je suis pas sûr qu'on y
arrivera aujourd'hui mais on aura
l'occasion d'en parler rationnellement
ave avec des échanges qui nous
intéresseront bien sûr mais une fois
qu'on a dit ça on va donc créer une
nouvelle circulaire dont l'amendement
prend bien soin de marquer qu'il n'est
pas opposable bon alors on peut le
garder parce que par principe c'est ce
que veut pas non plus le ministère de
l'intérieur mais ça me paraî super
fitatoire mais on va pas proposer une
suppression de de cette de cette
disposition je pense même qu'elle
attirrait trop l'œil d'ailleurs de ceux
qui voudrai le contester mais je ferme
la parenthèse en revanche c'est bien une
circulaire une autre circulaire que
celle de la circulaire Vals donc on ne
durcit pas Vals on fait une autre
circulaire dont les dispositions de
possibl régularisation sont plus durcies
que l'article 3 qui avait été imaginé
bien évidemment même si l'article 3
avait été euh au cas par cas parce qu'en
fait il y a trois types d'AES
aujourd'hui il y a la laes Vals qu'on
connaît créé aussi par une mesure
législative il y a laaes compagnon
desmaus qui avait été imaginé par le
ministre colon qui qui fait que les gens
qui sont dans le parcours des Maus
peuvent être régularisés et puis il y a
une AES mineure qui devienne majeure
dans l'année de leur majorité on va dire
ça comme ça l'apprenti boulanger de de
17 ans et demi il est apprenti boulanger
il est aidé par le département il est
aidé par la République à 17 ans et demi
puis à 18 ans Lu cut de partir bon alors
évidemment tout le monde écrit pour dire
c'est pas possible on aime tous notre
apprenti boulanger il donc on a créé une
disposition qui permet de dire bah non
il termine son année comme étant
régulier donc là on cré une 4e AES c'est
ce que nous faisons dans les conditions
que Madame la rapporteur a précisé c'est
important parce que j'ai lu et relu que
on durciss s Vals mais ce n'est
évidemment pas ce que nous écrivons
alors cependant monsieur le Président je
donne un avis favorable au
669 de Monsieur aroche
671 monsieur benaroche
665 de Madame de La Gonterie pardon si
ce n'est pas ceux qui ont porté la voix
mais c'est ceux que j'ai dans mon dans
ma lias 675 de Monsieur benaroche et 661
de Madame de laacterie ça correspond en
fait à l'article 3 que vous reprenez
évidemment ici ou là par ceement je n'ai
pas cédé à la au dururcissement ou alors
à l'ouverture plus grande qu'aurait été
l'article 3 profitant du cas de BIS je
ne suis pas rentrer dans dans ce point
de vue donc je donne un avis défavorable
à tous les autres évidemment je je
soutiens le sous amend du gouvernement
quels que soient les résultats de de ces
de ces votes de sous-amendements je
donnerai un avis de sagesse en espérant
qu'il soit évidemment adopté l'article 4
bis souhaité par la majorité
sénatoriale merci Monsieur le
Ministre on va donc madame de La
Gonterie vous avez demandé la
parole non c'est un scrute un peu lui
allez-y c'est les deux monsieur le
Président expliation de vote sur le
sous-amendement 658 explication de vote
je vous faire un grand plaisir sur
l'ensemble avec plaisir madame de La
Gonterie plaisir alors pour mon groupe
nous voterons contre l'amendement 657
des rapporteurs nous voterons pour
l'ensemble des sous-amendements qui ont
été présentés quel qu'en soit les
auteurs à l'exception du sous-amendement
du
gouvernement un mot puisque je ne
reprends prendrai sans doute pas la
parole sur ce point tout à l'heure
j'indiquais que une version de
l'histoire avait été présentée que je
qualifiait d'histoire raconté aux
enfants je crois que personne n'est dupe
il fallait absolument conclure sur un
accord puisque monsieur reetaillot avait
très tôt indiqué que jamais il ne
voterait l'article 3 quel qu'en soit le
contenu d'ailleurs précisait madame
joura rapporteur il fallait donc se
débarrasser de l'article 3 pas de chance
le groupe gr centriste avait identifié
l'intérêt de cet article 3 comment faire
sachant que la majorité au Sénat
nécessite l'accord de ces deux groupes
donc vous vous êtes rencontré réunis
déjeuné dîner pris le thé le café que
sais-je et idée de génie il a été décidé
de supprimer l'article 3 et ainsi de
satisfaire la demande de Monsieur
reetaillot de le réécrire ailleurs c'est
comme ça qui est arrivé l'article
additionnel a prè le le 4 et puis il
fallait quand même être un petit peu
strict donc vous avez allongé la durée
de travail nécessaire en passant de 8
mois à 12 mois vous avez remis
l'employeur avec une formulation qui est
assez alambiquée mais qui anéantit la
suppression justement ce qui était
l'intérêt de l'article 3 du gouvernement
de la suppression de de de de la
contribution de l'employeur au
process et puis vous avez ajouté un
petit peu d'ordre public et cetera parce
que ça ne gâche jamais s'agissant de la
droite pour limiter un petit peu les
droits donc tout ça semble-t-il mais
alors après vous avez un problème de
communication entre vous puisque chacun
dit que il a gagné le gouvernement aussi
ce qui est absolument rigoureusement
impossible donc on verra qui sortira
gagnant à l'extérieur monsieur
reetaillot a dégainé le premier monsieur
Marseille s'est dit quand même non non
non et puis monsieur Darmanin dit bah
c'est pas mal bon personne ne lit la
même chose dans ce que vous allez voter
en tout cas heureusement pour le coup
l'assemblée va faire le
travail merci madame de La Gonterie la
parole est à Monsieur ravier pour
explication de
vote je crois qu'on a besoin d'un
médecin du Galen peut-être oui
explication de vote monsieur le
Président merci la gauche nous refuse le
droit de voir l'immigration partout mais
depuis deux articles elle nous explique
qu'il y a des immigr partout dans toutes
nos cuisines nos champs nos entreprises
il y en a aussi beaucoup dans les
commissariats et et et dans les prisons
ça oublié de le dire et qu'il faudrait
donc régulariser sans quoi nous serions
dans un dénis de réalité et puis pas
seulement régulariser les clandestins
dans les métiers en tension je crois que
Madame Vogel a eu cette sincérité et je
vous en remercie que de souhaiter la
régularisation de tous les clandestins
il y en a jamais assez toujours plus
toujours plus cet amendement de la
droite sénatoriale c'est en réalité la
victoire de l'article 3 de Monsieur
Darmanin contre l'article 3 de la
Constitution article 3 de la
Constitution je vous le rappelle la
souveraineté nationale appartient au
peuple qu' l'exerce par ses
représentants par cet amendement vous
vous désaisissez mes chers collègues de
vos responsabilités de législateur en
laissant filer les régularisations
massives par voie réglementaire on nous
dit que ça sera du cas par cas on
c'estit ce que ça veut dire du cas par
cas un cas + un cas + un cas ça sera
tous les cas qui finiront par être tous
régularisés ça prendra sans doute un peu
plus de temps mais le résultat sera le
même sauf que vous aurez pris la
précaution mes chers collègues de droite
de ne pas emporter la responsabilité
mais infin ce sera la même chose alors
il faut savoir que la il faut le savoir
c'est régularisation massive oui ou
non j'ai j'ai j'ai ma petite idée donc
je rappelle quand même à la droite qu'il
y a d'autres voies de solution hausse
des salaires en réduisant l'écart entre
les salaires bruts et netes par la
réduction de 20 milliards annuels de
dépenses sociales non contributive le
RSA sous conditions système de formation
adaptée politique familiale et regain de
natalité merci monsieur le Président
merci merci Monsieur ravier la parole
est à Monsieur ho pour explication de
vote
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre
et oui madame de La gonriie c'est un
accord politique et un accord politique
c'est pas un gros mot et vous l'avez
moqué c'est un accord politique qui
révèle la solidité de la majorité
sénatoriale c'est peut-être qui vous
gêne c'est pe-être qui vous gêne c'est
un accord qui résulte d'un équilibre
d'une précaution je salue le le travail
des des rapporteurs d'une prudence aussi
et on a chois le cas par cas plutôt que
la régularisation systématique bah ma
foi c'est un choix c'est mais en tous
les cas on a avancé on a progressé et
ces deux ces deux dispositions
s'ajoutent avec la circulaire Vals elle
ne se substitue pas ça n'est pas une
dégradation c'est un ajout et pour
reprendre une métaphore on est un peu
plus gentil avec les gentil maintenant
sur l'accord politique bon vous allez
tout de même pas nous donner des leçons
en matière d'accord accord politique
hein parce que quand on a signé l'accord
politique de laanupse permettez-moi il y
a plus de grand écart qu'il y en a parmi
nous désolé de vous dire ça et ensuite
le le principe de prudence le principe
de
prudence moi je vous
trouve bien confiant parfois en vous
écoutant
oui on aborde ces questions un peu les
mains tremblantes parce que le choc
démographique il est là on n'est pas
dans les années 80 parfois vous écoutant
je me disais ah ils ont envie de
ressortir les pancartes comme à la belle
époque touche pas à mon pote mais on est
plus à cette à ce moment-l mes chers
collègues et donc l'accord politique que
nous vous présentons et cet amendement
que nous allons à voter et bien c'est un
accord équilibré et responsable je vous
remercie la parole est à
Monsieur de
vote merci monsieur le Président comme
j'ai vu que ça vous a fait plaisir je
vais faire comme Madame de la ganterie
je vais défendre et expliquer le vote du
groupe sur la totalité des
sous-amendements d'une seule fois et en
plus je reviendrait pas sur le mécanisme
par lequel vous êtes arrivé à ce fameux
accord puisque Marie-Pierre de la
ganterie l'a démontré avec Briot mais je
voudrais quand même revenir sur deux
points qui me paraissent quand même
assez dramatiqu voire même assez
inquiétant pour notre société pour les
années à venir en tout cas s'ils étaient
conservés dans le texte de loi définitif
qui sortira après le passage de
l'Assemblée nationale et après une
commission mixte paritaire le premier
c'est laame je pas revenir longement on
en a discuté hier je comprends toujours
pas la position du gouvernement ni la
vie de sagesse qui a été donné après la
démonstration brillante qui a été fait
par la ministre concernant le fait que
il était absolument improductif et
inhumain de supprimer la me mais j'y
reviens quand même parce que ça restera
un marqueur du texte qui sort du Sénat
la suppression de la me le deuxième
c'est ce vote aujourd'hui sur la
régularisation des travailleurs sans
papier alors
régularisation partielle importante
moins importante nous la voulions nous
en ce qui nous concerne sans condition
vous la vouliez-vous monsieur le
ministre pour un certain nombre de
métiers attention à la fois pour les
travailleurs pour les mais aussi pour
satisfaire un certain nombre de demande
de l'activité économique de notre pays
et au final nous arrivons à quoi nous
arrivons que le gouvernement lui par
contre dans cet accord ce qui est clair
c'est un abandon total du gouvernement
sur ces deux points face à la droite
alors je dis face et je dis abondant en
fait il y avait-il vraiment un
affrontement je ne le pense pas ou bien
s'agit-il uniquement de tension
fratricide entre
des conceptions légèrement différente de
ce qu'il faut faire que quand est
l'article 3 du gouvernement
originel une expérimentation de la
régularisation de certains travailleurs
sur les zonesententions une automaticité
législative avec des critères définis de
telle façon ne pas défendre d'une d'une
de politique différente des préfets une
absence d'intervention de l'employeur
pour ne pas laisser les sans- papiier à
la merci d'employur
délicat et c'est ce que vous appelez
monsieur darmanet le point d'équilibre
du
texte il y a un certain nombre de
sous-amendements et je fais une
explication commune mes chers collègues
je laisse dépasser monsieur benaroche
comme j'ai d'ailleurs laissé dépasser
l'ensemble des orateurs qui sont
exprimés jusqu'à maintenant dans la
mesure où c'est une explication de vote
sur l'ensemble des sousamendements et
amendements qui vont suivre et donc j'en
j'en appelle à quelques tolérance qui
nous permettra de d'avoir un débat
complet et éclairé de la Haute Assemblée
est-ce qu'on est d'accord
mercici
monés je vous remercie ces
caractéristiques que je viens d'noncer
ça représenter pour le gouvernement un
point d'équilibre du texte je vais
encore REC citer ce qui a été dit par
par notre ministre nous avons besoin
d'une avancée législative pour
régulariser des personnes qui
mériteraient de l'êre quand l'employeur
s'y refuse je suis et c'est pas il y a
pas longtemps c'était à la fin de la
discussion générale hein je suis prêt au
compromis et notamment à le compléter en
intégrant le critère de respect des
valeurs de la République c'est ce que
vous déclarez et que nous a proposé la
commission des lois face au texte
initial vous conservez l'aspect
expérimental bien
entendu le compromis annoncé par le
ministre sur le respect des valeurs et
de la République et des modes de vie ben
il est bien présent puisqu'il correspond
en fait absolument à la philosophie que
vous souhaitiez le pouvoir
discrétionnaire du préfet bah il est
revenu et puisque c'est des conditions
qui sont non opposables à l'autorité
administrative la faculté de
régularisation ne devient qu'une
possibilité puisque le doit se voir
délivré remplacé par le peut se voir
délivré et l'intervention de l'employeur
vous la remettez au cœur du dispositif à
postériori certes mais en tout cas point
critique pour la délivrance de
l'autorisation de travail donc au final
le point d'équilibre n'est pas atteint
le ni celui que nous avons essayé
d'impulser avec un certain nombre de nos
collègues du Sénat et de l'Assemblée
nationale ni celui que le ministre
disait souhaité ni même d'ailleurs celui
que le les centristes à un moment donné
souhaitaent essayer de d'imposer ou en
tout cas de négocier avec la droite
merci mon cher collègue la parole est au
président retaillot
oui quand quand j'entends Olivier ben je
me retrouve moi dans la majorité
sénatoriale bravo Olivier sur le coup de
laanupess et ça nous a bien détendu à
minuit à minuit passé maintenant deux
observations deux observations la
première observation je crois qu'après
plusieurs heures de discussion il est
désormais bien clair que l'article va
créer l'amendement de Jourda la
rapporteur n'a rien à voir avec
l'article 3 la preuve la preuve le
ministre était très défavorable avait un
ami avis défavorable sur la suppression
d'article 3 la preuve c'est vous mes
chers collègues de gauche qui l'a donné
puisque vous étiez farouchement accroché
farouchement accroché à la suppression
non contre la suppression d'article 3 et
là vous ne voulez sur pas de
l'amendement de M Juda preuve que dans
les deux il y a bien une vraie
différence et puis faut lire aussi
dernier dernière preuve l'intervention
dans le Figaro de monsieur sachaoulier
qui est l'homologue de François nel
buffet à l'Assemblée nationale je je le
lis et je le cite à l'Assemblée nous
rétablirons le texte ambitieux de
l'exécutif tout le texte de l'exécutif
les choses sont très claires et pour
terminer 2è observation nous avons voulu
par ce texte et par l'amendement de
Murel Jourda d'urcir oui les conditions
habituelles de la circulaire Vals
d'abord on proclame à nouveau par
rapport à l'article 3 qu'il n'y aura
jamais de droit automatique à la
régularisation et ensuite on durcit un
certain nombre de points qui sont très
clairs ça ne sera plus 8 mois sur 24
mois de travail ce sera 12 mois il y
aura une instruction un examen du préfet
à 360° sur l'ordre publici mais aussi
sur le respect des principes
républicains il y aura aussi il y aura
aussi bien sûr c'est le salarié qui va
déclencher la procédure mais on a un
dispositif antifraude par rapport à
l'article 3 parce que dès lors que le le
salarié l'employé clandestin aura
déclenché la procédure le préfet va
vérifier factctuellement concrètement
euh la réalité du travail en se
retournant vers l'employeur et j'espère
qu'il y aura des employeurs qui seront
punis mes chers collègues pour avoir
utilisé frauduleusement une main d'œuvre
voilà ce que je voulais dire et enfin il
y a bien sûr un délai c'est-à-dire qu'au
31 décembre 2026 l'expérimentation
chararrêtera merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre quelqu mots très
rapide parce que j'ai l'impression que
Bruno rotago a vraiment très envie de
dire qu'il est favorable à l'article de
régularisation dans sexe donc je le
remercie vraiment euh beaucoup revenir à
trois fois sur le sur le sujet un
monsieur le Président ce n'est pas
encore une fois euh un article demain le
CAD bis qui va durcir les conditions de
Vals je pense que on peut se dire les
choses comme sont il y aura une autre
circulaire qui va s'additionner à Vals
et elle sera différente mais elle ne
durcit rien du tout puisque comme il y a
rien c'est V que le durcissement du rien
est difficile il y a une nouvelle
circulaire avec des conditions que vous
avez fixé par exemple aujourd'hui une
femme qui n'a pas d'enfant et qui est
embauché par un patron voyou que
celui-ci ne veut pas le régulariser la
la régulariser pardon n'est pas
régularisable dans aucune condition sauf
si elle a un enfant et dans ces cas-là
on peut la régulariser au nom de Vals
pas travail mais Vals famille bon ce que
nous faisons ça me paraît assez logique
on dit à cette dame qu'on peut la
régulariser imaginons que le préfet
aurait voulu la régulariser parce
qu'elle aurait aurait constaté ce que
vous évoquez voilà il ne peut pas le
faire en Val c'est la loi l'interdit il
ne peut le faire que parce qu'elle a un
enfant donc en fait on encourage le fait
d'avoir des enfants pour être
régularisés donc il fallait bien c'est
la démonstration et j'en suis heureux
qu'après de long longues semaines de
discussion par médiia interposé monsieur
le Président on arrive à cette évidence
commune il faut donc une disposition
législative qui crée une nouvelle
circulaire puisque c'est votre choix
avec ce avec ce CAD bis qui qui ne
durcit rien du tout qui fait un autre
une autre circulaire donc il y a la Vals
qui ne bouge pas vous ne durcissez rien
du tout dans Vals vous ne l'avez pas
proposé vous créez une autre circulaire
selon les conditions du du 4 bis alors
par ailleurs vous dites il faut être
très dur contre les patrons voillou et
j'espère qu'ils sert sanctionnés je vous
encourage donc à être cohérent et à
voter l'article 8 que vous avez supprimé
en commission des lois donc ça je prends
de l'avance pour le prochain débat parce
que là on a des sanctions financières
extrêmement forte et malheureusement je
le constate comme vous les tribunaux
judiciaire ne condamne pas beaucoup ces
ces ces ces personnes alors même que
nous faisons beaucoup de procédures avec
l'expression du travail donc je pense
que l'article 8 faudra qu'il soit qu'il
soit rétabli et donc je pense en effet
qu'on peut désormais si c'est possible
voter C bis qui est donc un article de
régularisation et je m'en félicite on va
le faire très vite monsieur le ministre
non non mais on va quand même entendre
les explications de Monsieur
dossuurou et monsieur kerouge qui a
demandé la parole oui merci monsieur le
Président le ministre vous a bien
expliqué la façon dont vous vous êtes
fait un petit peu rouler tout de même
bon vous avez introduit dans ce texte
tout ce que vous aviez dans vos fonds de
tiroir à vous vous êtes allé aussi
piocher un peu dans les fonds de tiroir
du rassemblement national pour
introduire toute une galaxie de
disposition tout plus horrible les unes
que les autres et puis vous êtes arrivé
à ce compromis politique qui crée un
nouveau un une façon d'avoir un titre de
séjour nouvelle façon de pour l'étranger
qui de seevoir délivrer une carte de
séjour c'est le texte de votre de votre
amendement et donc tout de même dans ce
texte il y a une disposition qui
m'interroge sur la la vérification du
mode de vie je me demande quels sont les
moyens qui vont être déployés par
l'autorité compétente pour vérifier la
compatibilité du mode de vie avec euh
les valeurs de la République et euh et
les principes de la République
et comment on va vérifier ça sur quel
respect de la vie privée on va vérifier
ça avec quelle preuve matérielle quel
outil de
surveillance et puis comme ça n'est pas
opposable on va pouvoir raconter
n'importe quoi et raconter n'importe
quoi on l'a déjà vu au plus haut niveau
de l'État quand un ministre de
l'Intérieur s'est pris s'en est pris un
footballeur en racontant n'importe quoi
sur son mode de vie sur la façon de
l'étayer sur des complicités possibles
avec les Frères musulmans en étant
incapable de le prouver sur rien et oui
c'est c'est aussi c'est aussi ces
exemples qui viennent d'en haut qui
inspirent ce genre de texte et à la fin
on a l'arbitraire de l'État qui pourra
dire n'importe quoi sur les étrangers
puisque rien n'est opposable et donc
vous mettez à la mercie de l'arbitraire
administratif les étrangers en
France la parole est à Monsieur kerouche
pour explication de vote
oui merci monsieur le Président alors on
a on a eu 50 nuances d'explication d'un
accord politique céit assez cé c'était
c'était assez amusant alors autant
s'agissant de cette de cette d'acord
politique j'ai trouvé que le monsieur
monsieur boncarer était plus dans le
raison funèbre autant j'ai trouvé
monsieur ho relativement frétillant dans
la brosse à reluire ça je je dois je
dois l'avouer avec un certain humour
également parce que quand on parle de
mains tremblante alors qu'on vient de
détruire un texte au marteau j'ai trouvé
que ça relevait effectivement d'un
certain sens de de l'humour une fois que
une fois qu'on a dit ça ce texte
s'appelle immigration et intégration et
il porte aussi sur il porte aussi sur le
destin des des étrangers et pour revenir
à des choses plus factuelles il y a
justement une note qui a été publiée par
Linse le 30 mars dernier qui s'appelle
immigré et descendant d'immigré en
France et juste vous en livrer la
substance parce qu'elle contraste
fortement avec tout ce dont on discute
aujourd'hui non non non non c'est une
note de c'est une note de lin ça
s'appelle vous savez c'est c'est
l'organisme qui fait des vous savez ce
que c'est voilà
donc c'est
ça donc après on peut contester bien
entendu je sais que c'est l'habitude
tous c'est tous les travaux qui sont des
travaux factuels mais ça devient alors
très compliqué et on on va plutôt du
côté des fantasmes de l'extrême droite
et donc ce texte nous dit pas qu'il y a
pas de difficulté s'agissant de la
population immigrée il y a des problème
de logement on parle du taux de pauvreté
monétaire on parle des difficultés
vis-à-vis du marché du travail mais il y
a un mais c'est que dès qu'on
s'intéresse aux descendants d'immigrés
globalement le diplôme de ces enfants
d'immigrés et leur répartition par
catégorie socio-pressionnelle est très
proche de la moyenne nationale que
un/ers des fils et des fills d'ouvriers
immigrés deviennent cadres où exercent
une profession intermédiaire et que il y
a une nette ascension sociale qui se
double d'un brassage assez rapide plus
d'un descendant d'immigré sur deux a un
parent non imigré la mixidée des unions
augmente au fil des générations et en
matière religieuse induit une dynamique
de sécularisation les 2/ers des
descendants d'immigrés vivent avec une
personne sans ascendance migratoire et
90 % des descendants adultes de la 3e
génération sont d'ascendance européenne
on est donc très loin de l'vasion il y a
des catastrophes dans l'intégration
qu'il faut combattre et c'est ce que
nous faisons collectivement mais et
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir et que vous
ne voulez pas voir c'est que la tendance
générale est encourageante et vous la
niez à travers toutes les caricatures
que vous avez
exposé merci mes chers collègues je mets
au vote le sous-amendement 658 avec un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 674 avec avis défavorable de
la commission et du gouvernement même
vote même vote le 659 avis défavorable
avis défavorable même vote le 670 même
vote le 660 même
vote le
672 même vote le 661 avec avis
défavorable de la commission et avis
favorable du
Gouvernement même
vote non alors on passe au voix qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le 675 avec avis favorable du
Gouvernement et défavorable de la
commission même vote le 665 mêmes avis
même
vote le 671 mêmes avis même
vote nous en venons au 673 avec avis
défavorable de la commission avis
défavorable du gouvernement
alors on va passer au voix madame la
Présidente qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il n'est pas adopté le 666
même
vote le 668 même
vote nous en arrivons à l'amendement du
Gouvernement qui a reçu un avis
favorable de la commission
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté le sousamendement 662 avec avis
défavorable de la commission défavorable
du gouvernement qui est
pour il est pas on y
plus voilà il est il est sur le
dérouleur numérique donc 66 62 qui est
pour tout en haut madame de laonterie
qui est contre qui s'abstient il n'est
pas adopté le 667 même vote le 663 même
vote le 669 a reçu un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis favorable du
Gouvernement même même
vote le 664 avec double avis défavorable
de la commission du gouvernement
même vote très bien nous en avons fini
avec les sousamendements et nous en
revenons maintenant avec
un vote sur l'amendement 657 pour
lesquels j'ai été saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public de la part du groupe
républicain et de la part du groupe
socialiste écologique et
républain l'avis de la av du
gouvernement sur cet amendement est un
avis de
sagesse5
657 l'amendement ainsi
sous-amendé le scrutin est
ouvert il est minuit 21 sur l'antenne de
Public Sénat nous sommes toujours en
direct comme depuis le milieu de
l'après-midi pour suivre l'examen le 3è
jour de l'examen du projet de loi
immigration au Sénat et c'est un moment
très important qui se joue en ce moment
puisque le Sénat vote sur un amendement
qui vient créer un nouvel article et qui
va ainsi se substituer à l'article 3 du
projet de loi immigration un nouvel
équilibre qui a été trouvé autour d'un
et bien d'un renforcement de la
circulaire Vals dans un nouvel article
et qui vient donc prendre la place de
l'article 3 c'est le fruit de l'accord
entre sénateur LR et centriste un accord
qui a été scellé hier et qui et bien se
faisait depuis plusieurs semaines
plusieurs mois il n'avait pas été trouvé
jusque- là et donc c'est autour de cet
amendement qui est en train d'être voté
en ce moment même que bien la clé de
voûte du projet de loi immigration dans
sa version du Sénat va et bien pouvoir
se construire c'est donc très important
ce qui se joue mais sans surprise la
droite et le centre devrai adopter cet
amendement et donc créer ce nouveau
article additionnel après l'article 4
qui est donc une nouvelle circulaire
Vals avec de nouvelles précisions plus
personne ne demande à voter on va donc
avoir la cartographie exacte du vote
dans les prochaines
secondes on écoute6 contre 119 le Sénat
a
adopté l'ensemble des autres amendements
tombe mes chers collègues la séance a
été ouverte par la Conférence des
présidents pour la nuit je pense que
nous pouvons aller jusqu'à
2h on
continue article additionnel après
l'article
4 je suis saisi de quatre amendements
faisant l'objet d'une discussion commune
le
468 est présenté par Madame
greéhaum alors depuis tout à l'heure on
a parlé de beaucoup de personnes euh qui
est bah qui travaillit sans papier bien
entendu sauf que à force d'entendre
parler qu'il y a des gens qui
travaillent partout et que personne se
rend compte qu'ils ont pas de papier je
pense que ça serait bien que on puisse
avoir un rapport sur rapport sur
l'octroit des titres de séjour des
métiers en tension son application et
ses limites mais également qui
s'attachera également à mesurer l'impact
des régularisations sur les secteurs
économiques concernés je pense que ce
rapport est vraiment primordial il nous
semble essentiel de prendre la mesure de
ce qu'il représente dans notre pays et
nous nous est essentiel de mesurer ce
qu'il apporte à notre économie merci
voilà nous sommes en direct sur an de
Public Sénat pour tout comprendre on va
rejoindre notre journaliste Mathias Arz
Mathias l'amendement 657 a été adopté
qu'est-ce que ça signifie exactement
bien écoutez Quentin c'est un amendement
qui a été proposé par la Commission des
lois et qui devait donc re là
contrepartie de l'article 3 qui faisait
partie de l'accord entre centriste et LR
l'article 3 qui devait être supprimé
alors qu'est-ce qui distingue cet
amendement 657 de l'article 3 et bien
c'est tout simplement le fait que c cet
amendement crée la possibilité de
régulariser des travailleurs sans
papierers au cas par cas et non de
manière systématique comme le voulait la
première version voulue par le
gouvernement si je si je peux me
permettre de de vous développer un petit
peu de cet amendement et bien c'est que
ce n'est qu'à titre exceptionnel et non
plus de plein droit comme le prévoyait
le gouvernement qu'un travailleur pourra
prétendre à la régularisation à
condition d'avoir exercé pendant au
moins 12 mois sur les deux dernières
années dans des métiers et zones
géographique caractérisé par des
difficultés de recrutement voilà le
demandeur devra également justifier de
plusieurs critères notamment la
résidence de manière ininterrompue
depuis au moins 3 ans pour bénéficier de
ce titre d'au moins 1 an une procédure
strictement encadrée et qui ne pourra
euh être débloqué que par le pouvoir
discrétionnaire des préfets voilà
Quentin c'est un accord LR centriste on
l'a entendu plusieurs fois ce soir un
accord euh politique qui porte tout de
même bien la pâte
deslr et bien merci Mathias pour toutes
ces explications je vous propose de
retourner en séance quelques instants et
puis on fera un petit recéap sur tout ce
qu'il faut retenir de cet après-midi et
de cette soirée sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat merci pour le 476 la parole est à
Monsieur Beatz merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Ministre chers
collègues par cet amendement il s'agit
également donc de prévoir
l'annualisation de l'actualisation de la
liste des Mét en tension et de répondre
à la fois à l'invitation qui a était
faite par le Conseil d'État de cibler le
niveau le nouveau dispositif qui était
prévu sur les métiers zones
géographiques en tension et de prévoir
une une mise à jour régulière donc de
leur de leur liste le gouvernement ayant
déjà exprimé sa volonté de procéder à
cette actualisation annuelle il s'agit
ici de la concrétiser je vous
remercie le 383 on arrive à la fin de
cette édition spécial sur Public Sénat
pour bien suivre l'examen du projet
immigration on va rejoindre Mathias Arz
une dernière fois Mathias vous allez
nous raconter tout ce qui s'est joué
depuis 16h 17h et qu'on a vécu ensemble
il y a eu des des moments importants
dans l'examen de ce projet deimmigration
n'est-ce pas absolument Quentin c'est un
gros morceau du texte qui s'est joué ce
soir ici dans dans l'hémicycle tout
simplement c'est des articles 3 et 4
dont dépendait la la survie he du texte
tout simplement ici on savait les
centristes voulaaiit ces articles les LR
n'en voulait pas il y a donc été
question d'un accord on a entendu la
gauche regrettter la suppression de ces
articles des articles et un accord
surtout qui qui a qui a donné lieu à une
passe d'armes entre Bruno rotaillot et
Gérald haranin le président des
républicains ici au Sénat reprenchant au
ministre de l'Intérieur de s'approprier
le succès de cet accord je vous propose
de
l'écouter alors c'est extraordinaire
monsieur le ministre vous manquez pas
d'air je sais qu'en politique le culot
c'est souvent une qualité je le
reconnais et vous voulez faire croire
que le dispositif proposé par la
majorité sénatoriale c'est l'équivalent
finalement de du dispositif que vous
proposiez mais Queen neni ou alors les
groupes de gauche se trompent pourquoi
est-ce que tous les groupes de gauche
montent au créneau parce que eux voient
bien la comparaison et ils savent bien
que la proposition qu'on fait c'est pas
du tout la proposition initiale qui
était le sommet le paroxisme de la
macronie le en même temps pourquoi on
s'opposait et pourquoi c'est beaucoup
plus restrictif parce que vous l'article
3 notamment c'est un droit automatique
vous fraudez et plus longtemps vous
fraudez plus la fraude est dissimulée et
plus ça vous génère et plus la fraude
est créatrice de droit d'un droit
opposable d'un droit automatique que
même l'administration ne pourra pas
stopper bah nous on voulait pas et c'est
pour ça qu'on va le supprimer un Bruno
retaillot remonté hein vous l'avez
entendu qui tire la couverture une
attaque que ne pouvait évidemment pas
laisser un géralde d'armanin rompu à
l'exercice monsieur le Président vous ne
vouliez pas d'article régularisation
vous avez obtenu un compromis politique
et c'est normal c'est comme ça qu'on
fonctionne dans une assemblée
parlementaire la vérité qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé pour ceux qui nous écoutent
il s'est passé de la la politique
parlementaire il y avait une majorité
pour ne pas supprimer l'article 3 et il
n'y aurait une majorité pour voter en
revanche contre le texte puisque l'ELR
nurait n'aurait pas été majoritaire
quand monsieur Marseille a déposé son
amendement pour pas supprimer l'article
3 et évidemment mes amis de la gauche
aurait été très content de faire tomber
le ministre de l'Intérieur en votant
contre le texte final tout en votant
l'article 3 alors j'ai un instinct de
survie assez développé depuis quelques
années et donc je veux vous dire ici que
la politique la politique c'est c'est
simple ça se battre pour des convictions
essayer d'avoir 100 % de ses convictions
et quand on peut en avoir 50 % et bien
on peut être plus heureux ça s'appelle
un parti du gouvernement ça s'appelle
prendre ses responsabilités voilà en
réalité il y a bien une distinction
entre la copie du gouvernement et les
mesures prise ce soir par le Sénat et
bien c'est la prise en compte du cas par
cas pour l'obtention d'un titre de
séjour dans les métiers en tension et
bien merci Mathias pour ce récit et donc
on l'a compris c'est bien ce qui s'était
noué autour de l'accord entre LR et
centrist qui s'est déroulé depuis cet
après-midi et toute la soirée jusqu'à
maintenant suppression de l'article 3 et
4 et durcissement de la circulaire Vals
c'est la fin de cette émission retour de
ce grand direct ici en salle des
conférences pour de longues heures
d'examen de la réforme des retraites à
14h30 demain n'hésitez pas à lire les
articles de la rédaction sur notre site
c'est publixana.fr et merci à toutes les
équipes éditorial et technique